Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode describes acts of violence against a child that won't be suitable for all listeners. It was no secret that Lindy Chamberlain longed for a daughter. She and her husband Michael already had two sons, six-year-old Aidan and four-year-old Regan, and Lindy hoped her third pregnancy would result in a girl.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上的本集节目简介。本集讲述了针对儿童的暴力行为，并非适合所有听众。林迪·张伯伦渴望拥有一个女儿，这并不是什么秘密。她和丈夫迈克尔已经有了两个儿子，六岁的艾丹和四岁的里根，林迪希望她的第三胎是个女孩。
At 9.16 on the morning of June 11, 1980, she gave birth to a healthy daughter. Weighing three kilograms with dark eyes, black hair and olive skin, Lindy and Michael named her Azaria Chantel Lauren Chamberlain. When Azaria was less than a day old, she opened her mouth into a nose shape and blew a bubble, earning her the nickname of Bubbles. She was quiet, placid and easy to look after. She rarely cried unless she was in pain or hungry and would typically wake up without a stir.
1980年6月11日上午9点16分，她生下一个健康的女儿。她体重三公斤，有着黑眼睛、黑头发和橄榄色的皮肤，林迪和迈克尔给她取名为阿扎里娅·尚特尔·劳伦·张伯伦（Azaria Chantel Lauren Chamberlain）。当阿扎里娅出生还不到一天时，她把嘴巴张成鼻子形状并吹出一个泡泡，这为她赢得了“泡泡”的昵称。她很安静、温顺且很好照顾。她很少哭闹，除非感到疼痛或饥饿，而且通常醒来时也不会发出声响。
Guests would often ask where Azaria was, only to realise she was already in the room, silently observing the world around her. She spent her days babbling and giggling to herself in her bouncer net while watching her mother work around the house or lying beside her older brothers as they played. Regan was protective of his baby sister, helping tend to her needs and boasting to others about how wonderful she was. During a trip to the supermarket when Azaria was five weeks old, she was resting in the baby seat of a shopping trolley with Regan clinging to the side.
客人们经常问阿扎里娅在哪里，却发现她其实已经在房间里，正静静地观察着周围的世界。她白天大部分时间都在弹跳网里自言自语地咿呀学语、咯咯傻笑，看着妈妈在屋里干活，或者躺在哥哥们身旁看他们玩耍。里根对这个小妹妹非常保护，不仅帮忙照顾她的需求，还向别人吹嘘她是多么招人喜爱。在阿扎里娅五周大的一次超市之行中，她正躺在购物车婴儿座椅里，里根则紧紧抓着购物车的一侧。
Regan leaned over to look at some scales and the shift in weight caused the trolley to flip, sending Azaria onto the concrete floor. She was taken to the doctor who determined she hadn't sustained any injuries and was strong and well developed for her age. By her six-week check-up, the doctor was impressed with Azaria's progress, describing her as fit and healthy with a direct and knowing smile. Michael hadn't been able to spend much time with his new daughter as he had to leave for a five-week mission right after her birth.
里根俯身去看一些秤，体重的转移导致购物车翻倒，把阿扎里娅甩到了水泥地面上。她被送到医生那里，医生判定她没有受伤，而且就她的年龄而言，她身体强壮、发育良好。到了六周大的体检时，医生对阿扎里娅的发育印象深刻，称她身体健康、状况良好，并带着直接而聪明的微笑。迈克尔没能花太多时间陪伴新生女儿，因为他在她出生后不久就不得不动身去执行一个为期五周的任务。
He worked long hours as a minister for the Seventh Day Adventist Church, a job that uprooted his family every couple of years and often sent him on cross-country trips. Lindy was a devoted member of the church and often accompanied Michael on his missions, but this time opted to stay home with the children. It was looking forward to the upcoming school holidays when Michael would return and the family could spend some quality time travelling together. When Azaria was nine weeks old, the Chamberlains packed up their canary yellow Tarana hatchback and set out on an interstate road trip, heading 160km west from their home in northwest Queensland
作为基督复临安息日会的牧师，他工作时间长，这份工作让他的家庭每隔几年就要搬迁一次，还经常派他去进行跨国旅行。林迪是该教会的虔诚成员，经常陪同迈克尔执行任务，但这次她选择留在家里照顾孩子。她正期待着即将到来的学校假期，那时迈克尔就会回来，全家可以一起度过美好时光并到处旅行。在阿扎里娅九周大时，张伯伦一家收拾好他们金丝雀黄色的托拉娜（Torana）两厢车，踏上了州际公路之旅，从昆士兰州西北部的家向西行驶160公里，
and into the Northern Territory. Soon as the Red Centre, the area is considered the gateway to Australia's vast, arid and sparsely populated outback. The magnificent natural landmarks, desert plains, weathered mountain ranges and sacred sites presented plentiful opportunities for Michael to indulge in his passion for photography. Their plan was to visit the main tourist sites, camping along the way, before reaching Darwin on the north coast for a relaxing beachside conclusion where Michael could fish for Baramundi. Lindy and Michael were seasoned campers and had travelled with Aidan and Regan when they
进入北领地。红土中心（The Red Centre）不久便呈现在眼前，这片地区被认为是通往澳大利亚广阔、干旱且人烟稀少的内陆门户。壮丽的自然地标、沙漠平原、历经风化的山脉和圣地，为迈克尔沉溺于他的摄影爱好提供了充足的机会。他们的计划是参观主要的旅游景点，沿途露营，然后到达北海岸的达尔文市，在一个轻松的海滨终点结束行程，迈克尔可以在那里钓澳洲肺鱼。林迪和迈克尔都是经验丰富的露营者，在艾丹和里根还是婴儿时就带着他们旅行过，
were babies and felt confident about taking Azaria on their latest outing. Their journey commenced on August 13, 1980. Michael drove west across the border, navigating the long highways into the Northern Territory's desolate and remote countryside, stopping occasionally for fuel and rest breaks. When they reached the town of Tennant Creek, the family wandered around the local shopping district before heading 100km south to camp among the ancient boulders of the Devil's Marbles Conservation Reserve. The next morning, they continued heading south until they arrived in the town of Vallas Springs.
因此他们对带阿扎里娅踏上这次最新的出行感到很有信心。他们的旅程始于1980年8月13日。迈克尔驾车向西穿过边界，沿着漫长的高速公路驶入北领地荒凉偏远的乡村，偶尔停下来加油和休息。当他们到达滕滕克里克（Tennant Creek）小镇时，一家人先在当地的购物区闲逛，然后向南行驶100公里，在魔鬼大理石保护区（Devil's Marbles Conservation Reserve）古老的巨石间露营。第二天早上，他们继续向南行驶，直到抵达瓦拉斯斯普林斯（Vallas Springs）镇。
On midday on Saturday, August 16, the Chamberlains hit the road again. Michael had been documenting the holiday with his camera and pulled over on the Stuart Highway to snap a picture of his family. Lindy stood to the left of the Tirana with baby Azaria in her arms, as Regan and Aidan posed together to her right. Above them was a large road sign pointing to their next destination, Uluru. Uluru Uluru lies in the UNESCO World Heritage Listed Uluru Katajuta National Park, a vast outback
1980年8月16日星期六中午，张伯伦一家再次上路。迈克尔一直在用相机记录假期，他把车停在斯图尔特公路（Stuart Highway）旁，为家人拍了一张照片。林迪站在托拉娜汽车的左侧，怀里抱着婴儿阿扎里娅，里根和艾丹则并肩摆好姿势站在她右侧。在他们上方是一个巨大的路标，指向他们的下一个目的地——乌鲁鲁（Uluru）。乌鲁鲁乌鲁鲁坐落在被联合国教科文组织列为世界遗产的乌鲁鲁-卡塔久塔国家公园内，这是一个广阔的内陆
region characterised by dusty red sand deserts and isolated mountain ranges. The ancient sandstone monolith, which is believed to have started forming around 550 million years ago, stands 348 metres high and is surrounded by springs, waterholes and rock caves, some of which contain ancient Aboriginal art. It has immense spiritual significance to the traditional landowners, the Ananu people, who have lived in the area for tens of thousands of years. The name Uluru is a proper noun from the dialect of the Ananu people, but in English it is also known as Ayres Rock, as named by Australian explorer William Gross, who cited the landmark
地区，以尘土飞扬的红色沙漠和孤立的山脉为特征。这块古老的砂岩巨石据信大约开始形成于5.5亿年前，高348米，周围环绕着泉水、水坑和岩洞，其中一些洞穴包含古老的原住民艺术。对于传统土地所有者阿南古人（Anangu）来说，它具有巨大的精神意义，他们在该地区已经生活了数万年。乌鲁鲁这个名字是阿南古人方言中的专有名词，但在英语中它也被称为艾尔斯岩（Ayres Rock），这是由澳大利亚探险家威廉·戈斯（William Gosse）命名的，他在1873年
in 1873. The first vehicular track to the rock was constructed in 1948, paving the way for tour bus services and eventually a camping ground, motels and an airstrip. Uluru quickly established itself as a popular tourist destination, with visitors often climbing up its rock face to observe the sprawling desert landscape from its peak. As more people arrived to participate in the steep track, a chain handrail was installed to help facilitate the climb. In 1980 Ayres Rock Campground was the only tourist camping area within close proximity
记录了这个地标。通往这块巨石的第一条机动车道建于1948年，为旅游巴士服务的开通铺平了道路，随后这里还建成了露营地、汽车旅馆和简易机场。乌鲁鲁迅速确立了自己作为热门旅游目的地的地位，游客们经常攀登其岩壁，从山顶俯瞰绵延的沙漠景观。随着越来越多的人前来参与这条陡峭的小路攀登，人们安装了一条链式扶手来帮助协助攀登。1980年，艾尔斯岩露营地是紧邻
of Uluru. Nighttime was already approaching by the time the Chamberlains arrived there on Saturday August 16. They had aimed to arrive sooner to give Michael the opportunity to take photos of the rocket dusk, but had made numerous stops on the 450km drive from Alice Springs, which ultimately slowed them down. The Chamberlains planned to stay for three days and were told to search the designated area for an available spot.
乌鲁鲁的唯一旅游露营区。8月16日星期六，当张伯伦一家到达那里时，夜幕已经降临。他们原本的目标是早点到达，以便让迈克尔有机会在黄昏时分拍摄巨石的照片，但从爱丽丝泉（Alice Springs）出发的450公里车程中，他们做了多次停留，这最终拖慢了他们的速度。张伯伦一家计划逗留三天，并被告知要在指定区域寻找一个空位。
Given it was school holidays, the grounds were relatively full, already catering to hundreds of campers. They drove towards the back, far enough away to ensure Azaria would not disturb other guests should you cry throughout the night, and pulled up next to a sand dune known as Sunrise Hill, a popular vantage point at dawn on the eastern edge of the campground. They set up camp alongside a picnic table, with the only source of light coming from a 100w portable floodlight tied to a wooden post in the communal barbecue area 25m east. They positioned their yellow multi-person tent facing Uluru.
鉴于正值学校假期，营地相对拥挤，已经接待了数百名露营者。他们把车开向后方，距离足够远，以确保阿扎里娅如果夜里哭闹不会打扰到其他客人，并把车停在被称为“日出山”（Sunrise Hill）的沙丘旁——这是营地东缘黎明时分的一个热门观景台。他们在野餐桌旁搭起营地，唯一的照明来源是系在25米东侧公共烧烤区一根木柱上的100瓦便携式泛光灯。他们将黄色的多人帐篷正面朝向乌鲁鲁。
The family of five then settled in the tent together to sleep. Azaria was placed in a white wicket basket that rested at the feet of her older brother Regan. During breakfast the following morning of Sunday August 17, the Chamberlains introduced themselves to several other campers, some of whom formed over baby Azaria in her carry basket. Afterwards, the family bundled into their Tirana to go sightseeing. Lindy had visited the Northern Territory during her teen years, but her photos of Uluru had
随后，这口五口之家一起在帐篷里安顿下来睡觉。阿扎里娅被放在一个白色藤条篮子里，放在大哥哥里根的脚边。第二天早上（8月17日星期日）吃早餐时，张伯伦一家向其他几位露营者作了自我介绍，其中一些人围着婴儿提篮里的阿扎里娅逗弄。之后，一家人挤进他们的托拉娜车去观光。林迪在十几岁时曾访问过北领地，但她关于乌鲁鲁的照片
since faded. She wanted to replace them with new ones, and Michael obliged, taking many photos, including one of Lindy holding Azaria up against the rock face. The Chamberlains returned to air's rock campground that evening. Lindy bathed the children, and dressed Azaria in a disposable nappy, singlet, a white jumpsuit, and a knitted matinee jacket, with pale lemon scalloped edging. She also put on a pair of white booties underneath the jumpsuit, so she didn't have to remove them every time Azaria's nappy required changing.
已经褪色。她想用新照片取而代之，迈克尔满足了她的愿望，拍了许多照片，其中包括一张林迪抱着阿扎里娅紧贴着岩壁的照片。当晚，张伯伦一家返回了艾尔斯岩露营地。林迪给孩子们洗了澡，给阿扎里娅穿上了一块一次性纸尿裤、一件短背心、一件白色连体衣，以及一件带有淡柠檬色扇形边缘的针织日间外套。她还在连体衣里面穿了一双白色小鞋，这样每次给阿扎里娅换尿布时就不必脱掉它们了。
A tired Regan was put to bed in the tent, while his two siblings remained up with their parents. At around 6.30pm, the Chamberlains joined some of the other campers at the communal barbecue area. Lindy and Michael chatted with another young couple, Greg and Sully Lowe, who took an immediate liking to the family. Sully noted that Lindy appeared cheerful, and had a new mum glow. Azaria was struggling to settle, so Lindy rewrapped the blankets around her, and she eventually stopped fussing and dozed off.
疲惫的里根被哄上帐篷睡觉，而他的两个兄弟则和父母待在一起。大约晚上6点30分，张伯伦一家与一些其他露营者加入了公共烧烤区的行列。林迪和迈克尔与另一对年轻夫妇格雷格（Greg）和苏莉·洛（Sully Lowe）闲聊，后者对这家人产生了好感。苏莉注意到林迪显得很高兴，身上散发着新手妈妈的光彩。阿扎里娅正烦躁不安难以入睡，于是林迪重新给她裹好毯子，她最终停止了哭闹并打起了瞌睡。
At 8pm, Lindy announced to the group, it's time I put Bubby down. She carried Azaria down the worn track that led towards the camp, with Aidan in tow. The front of the Chamberlains tent was visible from the barbecue area, and close enough to carry any sounds over in the quiet night. It was partly obscured by a railing, a low-lying fence and shrubbery, but Greg Lowe was able to glimpse Lindy kneeling as she entered the tent. Greg witnessed Lindy emerge a short time later, and move towards the family's terrana, which was parked against the tent's southern side.
晚上8点，林迪向大家宣布：“我该把小宝（Bubby）哄睡了。”她抱着阿扎里娅沿着通往营地的磨损小路走去，身后跟着艾丹。从烧烤区可以看到张伯伦帐篷的前方，而且在宁静的夜晚，距离足够近，能把任何声音传过去。它部分被一栏杆、一道矮栅栏和灌木丛遮挡，但格雷格·洛能够隐约看到林迪跪着进入帐篷。格雷格目睹林迪不久后从帐篷里出来，走向停在帐篷南侧的家族托拉娜车。
Lindy returned to the group 10 minutes later with Aidan. As she prepared Aidan some baked beans, he heard something whimpering and remarked, I think that is Bubby crying, in reference to Azaria. Sully Lowe had also heard the noise and believed it was Azaria. Lindy was certain Azaria was asleep, but Michael insisted she go check. Lindy returned to the tent by herself and exclaimed a short time later, my God, my God, a dingo has got my baby. Dingoes were not an uncommon sight around the campground.
10分钟后，林迪带着艾丹回到了人群中。当她为艾丹准备一些烤豆时，他听到有呜咽声并说：“我想那是小宝在哭”，指的是阿扎里娅。苏莉·洛也听到了这个声音，并认为那是阿扎里娅。林迪确信阿扎里娅已经睡着了，但迈克尔坚持让她去查看一下。林迪独自一人返回帐篷，不久后惊呼道：“天哪，天哪，一只野狗把我的孩子叼走了。”野狗在营地周围并不罕见。
The cavernous native dog, with typically red or tan fur, had a large presence in the red centre, where they travelled in packs of up to ten, lived in cave-like lairs, and hunted at night. They had grown accustomed to people over time, and were known to wander the campground and at surroundings for scraps left behind by visitors and hikers. Signs in the camp toilets warned against feeding them, and the chamberlains had stored their food in their car to avoid attracting them. Reagan was still inside the chamberlain tent, having slept through any goings-on, but Azaria's
这种体型庞大的本地犬，通常有着红色或黄色的皮毛，在红土中心有着极高的存在感，它们成群结队（多达十只）出行，住在洞穴般的巢穴里，并在夜间捕猎。随着时间推移，它们已经习惯了人类，众所周知，它们会在营地及其周围游荡，寻找游客和远足者留下的残羹剩饭。营地厕所的标语警告人们不要喂食它们，张伯伦一家已将食物存放在车里以避免吸引它们。里根仍然待在张伯伦的帐篷里，对发生的事情睡得很熟，但阿扎里娅的
basket was empty. Lindy was asked which way the dingo had gone, and she pointed in the opposite direction of Uluru towards the sand dunes. Her husband Michael and Greg Lowe started scouring the area, but it was dark and difficult to see anything beyond the low floodlight in the barbecue area. Several campers heard the commotion and came to the chamberlain's aid. Michael was given a torch, and he quickly returned to the dunes to continue the search. Lindy maintained that a dingo had taken Azaria, and when asked how she knew that, she explained
篮子是空的。有人问林迪野狗往哪个方向去了，她指向与乌鲁鲁相反的沙丘方向。她的丈夫迈克尔和格雷格·洛开始在四周搜寻，但天很黑，除了烧烤区的低矮泛光灯外，很难看清任何东西。几名露营者听到骚动前来协助张伯伦一家。迈克尔拿到了一把手电筒，他迅速返回沙丘继续搜寻。林迪坚称是一只野狗叼走了阿扎里娅，当被问及她怎么知道时，她解释说
that she had seen one coming out of the tent as she was walking towards it, and her baby was now missing. Several campers peered into the chamberlain's tent and noticed drops of blood on the floor. Murray Habie had been staying with his family in a van adjacent to the chamberlain's tent. He joined the search, taking a torch and heading east of the sand dunes. He crossed the ridge of the dunes and found what appeared to be track marks. He followed them and came across an imprint which looked as though an object had been placed down in the sand.
她在走向帐篷时看到一只野狗从里面出来，而她的孩子现在不见了。几位露营者探头向张伯伦的帐篷里面望去，注意到地板上有血迹。默里·哈比（Murray Habie）和家人一直住在张伯伦帐篷旁边的一辆房车里。他加入了搜寻，拿着手电筒朝沙丘东侧走去。他穿过沙丘山脊，发现了一些看起来像是脚印痕迹的东西。他顺着痕迹走去，发现了一个印记，看起来像是有什么东西被放在沙子里。
He summoned the park ranger in charge of the area, Derek Roth, who arrived at the scene at 8.25pm, followed shortly after by senior constable Frank Morris. Ranger Roth believed the imprint resembled the pattern of a knitted or woven garment. According to Lindy, she had placed Azaria in the basket with six blankets and a rug at her feet, as the temperature in the desert dropped significantly at night. She secured the blankets a centimeter from the crown of Azaria's head, creating a warm cocoon wherein only her face was visible. By this point, Azaria had been asleep for around half an hour.
他叫来了负责该地区的公园管理员德里克·罗斯（Derek Roth），后者于晚上8点25分抵达现场，随后高级警员弗兰克·莫里斯（Frank Morris）也赶到了。罗斯管理员认为这个印记类似于针织或编织衣物的图案。据林迪说，她在阿扎里娅脚边放了六条毯子和一个小地毯将她放在篮子里，因为沙漠夜间的温度显著下降。她把毯子固定在距离阿扎里娅头顶一厘米的地方，形成了一个温暖的茧，只有她的脸露在外面。此时，阿扎里娅已经睡了大约半小时。
Aidan crawled into the tent and kissed his baby sister Goodnight before tucking himself into his sleeping bag. But when he complained of still being hungry, he agreed to return to the barbecue area so his mother could fix him some baked beans. Aidan crawled out of the tent and waited nearby as Lindy went to the Tirana to fetch the baked beans and a can opener. The pair then headed back to the barbecue area together, with Lindy leaving the tent flap open as she soon planned to go to bed herself.
艾丹爬进帐篷，吻了吻熟睡的妹妹晚安，然后自己钻进睡袋。但当他抱怨肚子还饿时，他同意返回烧烤区，以便妈妈给他弄点烤豆。艾丹爬出帐篷，在附近等待，而林迪则去托拉娜车里拿烤豆和开罐器。随后两人一起返回烧烤区，林迪把帐篷帘子敞开着，因为她自己也打算很快去睡觉。
She told Constable Morris that as she went to check on Azaria, she saw a dingo emerging from the tent. Although she couldn't tell for certain through the darkness, its head appeared to be tilted slightly downwards and it looked as though it was carrying something in its mouth. When it fled, Lindy checked inside the tent, finding Azaria's blankets in disarray. The dummy was amongst them, still warm to the touch. Regan was asleep and unharmed, tucked into his sleeping bag with his face buried in his pillow.
她告诉莫里斯警员，当她去查看阿扎里娅时，她看到一只野狗从帐篷里钻出来。尽管她在黑暗中无法确切看清，但它的头部似乎略微向下倾斜，看起来嘴里叼着什么东西。当它逃跑时，林迪检查了帐篷内部，发现阿扎里娅的毯子凌乱不堪。安抚奶嘴在其中，摸上去还是温热的。里根正在睡觉且安然无恙，蜷缩在睡袋里，脸埋在枕头里。
Lindy bumped Azaria's basket which rolled over with ease, confirming her baby was no longer inside. Constable Morris shone a torch into the chamberlain's tent, where the basket, blankets and other items were strewn about. There were several spots of blood on the floor. Poor prints and drag marks were also noticeable in the dirt surrounding the tent. Lindy's story was supported by several other campers who had sighted dingo shortly before Azaria's disappearance.
林迪碰了一下阿扎里娅的提篮，它轻而易举地翻倒了，证实了她的孩子已经不在里面了。莫里斯警员用手电筒照进张伯伦的帐篷，里面篮子、毯子和其他物品散落一地。地板上有好几处血迹。帐篷周围的泥土中也能看到明显的爪印和拖拽痕迹。林迪的说法得到了几位在阿扎里娅失踪前不久见过野狗的露营者的支持。
Earlier that day, the chamberlains visited a local site called Fertility Cave, located at the base of Uluru, which featured Aboriginal rock paintings of sacred significance. While there, Lindy pointed out a dingo who was watching them from a rock above. She noted its behavior as creepy and later remarked, that's almost as if the dog had been casing the baby. That evening at Azaria's rock campground, a dingo followed Sally Lowe as she disposed of food scraps in a rubbish bin, and Michael had thrown a crust of bread to one as he prepared dinner.
当天早些时候，张伯伦一家参观了一个名为“生育洞”（Fertility Cave）的当地景点，该景点位于乌鲁鲁山脚下，上面有具有神圣意义的原住民岩画。在那里时，林迪指出了一只从上方岩石上注视着他们的野狗。她形容它的行为令人毛骨悚然，后来还评论道：“这几乎就像那只狗一直在踩点这个婴儿一样。”那天晚上在阿扎里娅岩石露营地，一只野狗在苏莉·洛将食物残渣扔进垃圾桶时尾随她，而迈克尔在准备晚餐时曾向其中一只扔了一块面包皮。
The Habie family had been eating dinner at around 8 o'clock when a dingo approached their van's sliding door. They took photos of it before it scurried away into the night. Bill and Judy West were staying at the campsite closest to the chamberlains. Five minutes before Lindy cried out for her daughter, they thought they had heard a dingo's low growl outside from the direction of the chamberlains' tent. 300 volunteers formed a human chain to search the rugged terrain to the north, east and south of the tent.
哈比一家在晚上8点左右吃晚餐时，一只野狗靠近了他们房车的推拉门。他们拍下了它的照片，随后它便急匆匆地跑入夜色中。比尔（Bill）和朱迪·韦斯特（Judy West）住在距离张伯伦一家最近的营地。在林迪为女儿大声呼救前五分钟，他们以为自己听到张伯伦帐篷方向的外面传来野狗的低沉咆哮声。300名志愿者组成了一道人链，在帐篷北部、东部和南部的崎岖地形中搜寻。
Aboriginal trackers with expertise in dingo tracking followed the paw prints and drag marks and reached a road where they mixed in with human footprints and were no longer distinguishable. The depth of the paw prints led the trackers to believe the animal had been carrying a load of some kind. The chamberlains remained at the campsite for the duration of this search. Azaria had been recovering from a cold, and given the icy night-time temperature, they believed that if she hadn't died as a result of the dingo attack, it wouldn't take long
具有野狗追踪专业知识的原住民追踪者顺着爪印和拖拽痕迹追踪，来到了一条路上，那里的印迹与人类脚印混在一起，再也无法辨认。爪印的深度让追踪者相信这只动物当时背负着某种重量。张伯伦一家在整个搜寻过程中一直留在营地。阿扎里娅一直在从感冒中恢复，鉴于冰冷的夜间气温，他们认为如果她没有死于野狗袭击，那么用不了多久
before she succumbed to pneumonia or froze to death. People remarked that Azaria was likely dead and that whatever happened was God's will. Aidan was distraught and told some of the gathering campers that a dingo had taken his sister and she was now in the dog's tummy. At one point, an agitated Lindy told the search parties that they were not looking in the correct area and they should be checking under nearby shrubs and bushes. She said, I will have to live with this the rest of my life and I don't want to think that the baby could have been out there and simply because we didn't look in the right
她就会死于肺炎或被冻死。人们议论说阿扎里娅很可能已经死了，无论发生了什么都是上帝的旨意。艾丹心烦意乱，告诉聚集的一些露营者，一只野狗叼走了他的妹妹，现在她已经在狗肚子里了。有一会儿，情绪激动的林迪告诉搜寻队他们没有在正确的区域寻找，他们应该检查附近的灌木丛。她说：“我余生都得带着这个阴影生活，我不想认为这个仅仅因为我们没有在正确地方寻找而可能还在那里的婴儿会死掉。”
place it would die. Lindy and Michael headed to the area that she had singled out, disappearing for roughly 15 to 20 minutes. At 1.30 am, with no sign of Azaria uncovered, the search was called off due to lack of visibility. The Chamberlains were persuaded to spend the night in a motel. The search for Azaria resumed at 5.30 the following morning. An examination of the Chamberlain's tent revealed several animal hairs on Azaria's basket and blanket as well as blood stains on various items including a sleeping bag,
林迪和迈克尔朝着她指定的那片区域走去，消失了大约15到20分钟。凌晨1:30，由于没有发现阿扎里娅的任何踪迹，搜寻工作因能见度不足而取消。张伯伦一家被说服在汽车旅馆过夜。第二天清晨5:30，搜寻阿扎里娅的工作恢复。对张伯伦帐篷的检查在阿扎里娅的提篮和毯子上发现了多根动物毛发，以及各种物品上的血迹，包括睡袋、
a floral mattress, a parka and a raincoat. There were also blood stains on Azaria's blanket which had been torn in a way that indicated it had been bitten. There was no blood on the basket nor any trailing out from the tent but a small blood spray pattern was identified on the exterior wall of the tent. Dingoes are strong predatory animals and given that Azaria weighed just 4.5kg, the police believed it was possible that one could have carried her in its jaws. 25 Dingoes were known to frequent Ares Rock campground and some had previously entered
碎花床垫、派克大衣和雨衣。阿扎里娅的毯子上也有血迹，毯子被撕裂的方式表明它曾被咬过。提篮上没有血迹，帐篷也没有血迹拖出的痕迹，但在帐篷外壁上发现了一个小的血迹喷溅图案。野狗是凶猛的掠食性动物，鉴于阿扎里娅体重仅4.5公斤，警方认为野狗完全有可能用下颌叼着她。众所周知，有25只野狗经常出没于艾尔斯岩露营地，其中一些以前曾进入
tents searching for food. They had become increasingly aggressive and potentially dangerous. In the two months leading up to Azaria's disappearance, six people had been treated for wild canine bites at Uluru. The day prior, three children had been attacked in separate incidents but none were seriously injured. A dingo had snagged the clothing of a 14 year old girl and her 9 year old brother with its teeth while another child had been bitten and pinned down.
帐篷寻找食物。它们变得越来越具有攻击性并且潜在危险。在阿扎里娅失踪前的两个月里，乌鲁鲁已有六人因遭到野生犬类咬伤而接受治疗。前一天，有三名儿童在不同的事件中遭到袭击，但都没有受重伤。一只野狗用牙齿咬住了14岁女孩和她9岁弟弟的衣服，而另一个孩子则被咬伤并被按倒在地。
In each of these incidents, the animals exhibited little fear of humans and were slow to retreat. Ranger Derek Roth was aware of an incident that occurred less than two months prior on June 23 in which a dingo seized a 3 year old girl around the head and dragged her from a car, relenting only after the girl's father intervened. The day before Azaria went missing, a woman sleeping in the garden adjoining Ranger Roth's house was approached by a dingo. It removed the pillow from under her head and then attempted to pull a sleeping bag away from her body.
在这些事件中，动物对人类几乎没有表现出恐惧，且撤退缓慢。管理员德里克·罗斯知道一起发生在不到两个月前（即6月23日）的事件，当时一只野狗抓住了一个3岁女孩的头部并将其从车里拖走，直到女孩的父亲进行干预才松口。在阿扎里娅失踪的前一天，一名睡在罗斯管理员家旁边花园里的女子遭到了一只野狗的接近。它抽走了她头下的枕头，然后试图从她身上扯走睡袋。
Ranger Roth had become so concerned about the spade of attacks that he had recently sought permission from his park superiors to begin shooting the wild animals. If Azaria had been taken by a dingo as Lindy alleged, the police held strong doubts that her body would ever be found. One officer remarked, There are dingo layers everywhere. If the baby has been taken into a cave, the possibility of recovery is almost nil. Both Lindy and Michael Chamberlain were willing to front news crews to answer questions.
罗斯管理员对这一系列袭击事件感到如此担忧，以至于他最近向公园上级寻求许可，开始射杀这些野生动物。如果阿扎里娅像林迪所说的那样被野狗叼走，警方对她的尸体是否能被找到抱有强烈怀疑。一名警官评论道：“到处都是野狗巢穴。如果婴儿被带进洞穴，找回的可能性几乎为零。”林迪和迈克尔·张伯伦都愿意面对新闻团队回答问题。
Michael told reporters, Thank you, all of you, for the efforts you are making to find our baby. Although we cannot believe there is hope any longer of finding her alive. I am a man of God, a minister of religion. I know that nothing happens in the world unless the good Lord wills it should be so. I know our baby has passed from us into heaven. My wife and I must not be sad, but jubilant that our little daughter is safe in the arms of Jesus.
迈克尔对记者说：“谢谢你们所有人，感谢你们为寻找我们的宝宝所做出的努力。尽管我们不再相信还有希望找到活着的她。我是个上帝的人，一个宗教牧师。我知道世上发生的一切，除非伟大的主愿意它如此发生。我知道我们的宝宝已经离开我们去了天堂。我和我的妻子不能悲伤，而应该欢欣鼓舞，因为我们的小女儿安全地躺在耶稣的怀抱里。”
He then described how they knew from the sharp, jagged marks in Azaria's blanket that she had been attacked by a very powerful beast. Lindy, who donned a pair of dark sunglasses and held Regan in front of the cameras, explained how she had witnessed the dingo emerge from the tent shortly after putting Azaria to bed. There wasn't time to go and tell people, I just yelled out, the dingo's got my baby. From the moment the Chamberlains checked in at the motel, they made no attempt to rejoin search efforts and did not inquire as to how the investigation was progressing. After two nights, they resigned to their belief that there was no chance their daughter would
随后他描述了他们如何从阿扎里娅毯子上尖锐、锯齿状的痕迹看出她遭到了非常强力的野兽袭击。林迪戴着一副墨镜，将里根抱在摄像机前，解释了她如何在将阿扎里娅哄睡后不久目睹野狗从帐篷里钻出来。当时没有时间去告诉别人，她只是大喊：“野狗把我的孩子叼走了。”从张伯伦一家在汽车旅馆登记入住的那一刻起，他们就没有试图重新加入搜寻工作，也没有询问调查进展如何。两天后，他们接受了他们的女儿无论死活都找不回来的想法，决定离开北领地。
be recovered, either dead or alive, and decided to leave the Northern Territory. They spent the morning of Tuesday, August 19 praying in their room, before commencing the drive home to Queensland in their Tarana. They stopped the dare's rock campground on the way so Michael could take some photos which he then sent to a newspaper. Their behaviour was under constant scrutiny, with the Australian public and media viewing the couple's uncharacteristic composure and blind acceptance of Azaria's fate as suspicious. Despite their initial acceptance that a dingo had taken Azaria, investigators were curious
8月19日星期二上午，他们在房间里祈祷，然后开着他们的托拉娜车踏上了回昆士兰的归途。他们在途中顺道去了艾尔斯岩露营地，以便迈克尔拍一些照片，然后他把这些照片寄给了一家报纸。他们的行为受到了持续的审视，澳大利亚公众和媒体认为这对夫妇对阿扎里娅命运的不寻常冷静和盲目接受令人怀疑。尽管他们最初接受了野狗叼走阿扎里娅的说法，但调查人员对他们认为林迪陈述中不一致的地方感到好奇。
about what they perceived as inconsistencies in Lindy's statements. She reportedly gave conflicting details to multiple people, including whether she saw something in the dingo's mouth or not. Journalists sought comments from authorities on dingo behaviour, with some saying it was highly unlikely that a dingo would take an infant, although they wouldn't rule out the possibility. The spade of dingo attacks in recent months gave credibility to Lindy's claims, however, there was no record of any other child ever being killed by a dingo.
据报道，她向多个人提供了相互矛盾的细节，包括她是否看到野狗嘴里有东西。记者们就野狗行为征求了当局的意见，一些人表示野狗叼走婴儿的可能性极低，尽管他们不排除这种可能性。近几个月来频发的野狗袭击事件赋予了林迪的说法一定可信度，然而，没有任何其他儿童被野狗杀害的记录。
Investigating Sergeant John Lincoln disputed that a dingo would have been capable of carrying Azaria for any great distance. To demonstrate his point, he filled a bucket with sand and attempted to lift it in his own mouth, but was unable to hold it up for longer than a minute. He then challenged his colleagues to do the same. After three days of widespread searching and no sign of the missing baby, it was publicly announced that there was no possibility of recovering Azaria alive. Meanwhile, Park Rangers started shooting dingoes and wild dogs around Uluru, then sent their remains for analysis in the hopes they would reveal something about Azaria's fate.
负责调查的警长约翰·林肯（John Lincoln）质疑野狗是否有能力将阿扎里娅叼出很远的距离。为了证明他的观点，他用沙子装满一个桶，并试图用自己的嘴将其提起，但无法坚持超过一分钟。然后他挑战他的同事们也这样做。经过三天的大规模搜寻且没有失踪婴儿的踪迹后，官方公开宣布找回活着的阿扎里娅已无任何可能。与此同时，公园管理员开始在乌鲁鲁周围射杀野狗和流浪狗，然后将它们的遗体送去做分析，希望能揭示一些关于阿扎里娅命运的信息。
At 4pm on Sunday, August 24, exactly one week after Azaria went missing, a young interstate family visiting Uluru set out on an afternoon walk to a gully near the rock's base. 35-year-old Wally Goodwin was a keen photographer and planned to capture some decent shots of wildflowers along the way. He kept to a track that was surrounded by dense foliage, while his son and daughter followed behind, and his wife Margo walked on higher ground to keep an eye on the children. The area they were hiking through was situated 400m from Fertility Cave and just over 5km from Air's rock campground. Wally and Margo sided a baby's jumpsuit and a torn-up disposable nappy on the ground near a boulder. The jumpsuit was crumpled and lying
8月24日星期日晚上4点，也就是阿扎里娅失踪整整一周后，一个访问乌鲁鲁的年轻州际家庭开始在岩石底部附近的一个沟渠进行下午散步。35岁的沃利·古德温（Wally Goodwin）是一位热心的摄影师，计划沿途拍摄一些不错的野花照片。他沿着一条周围环绕着茂密树叶的小路走，他的儿子和女儿跟在后面，妻子玛戈（Margo）则走在较高的地方照看孩子。他们徒步穿过的区域距离生育洞400米，距离艾尔斯岩露营地略超5公里。沃利和玛戈在巨石附近的地上看到了婴儿连体衣和撕破的一次性纸尿裤。连体衣揉成一团，正面朝上，领口周围可见血迹。
face up, with blood visible around the neckline. It had a series of pressed studs down the front, all of which appeared to be undone, and inside there was a singlet which was also covered in blood. Wally had heard the news reports about Azaria Chamberlain and knew this could be a significant find. Wary of disturbing the items, he made no attempt to look any closer and didn't take any photographs. Instead, he gathered his family and drove to the police station to notify the authorities. Constable Frank Morris, who had been a part of the Chamberlain case from the outset, was on duty when Wally arrived. The men travelled to the side of the clothing together, which was positioned adjacent to a dingo lair. Constable Morris picked up the clothes and
它前面有一排压扣，看起来全都解开了，里面有一件同样沾满血迹的背心。沃利听过关于阿扎里娅·张伯伦的新闻报道，知道这可能是一个重大发现。由于担心破坏这些物品，他没有试图仔细查看，也没有拍照。相反，他把家人聚集起来，开车去警察局通知当局。弗兰克·莫里斯警员从一开始就参与了张伯伦案，当沃利到达时他正在值班。两人一起前往衣物所在地，该地点位于一个野狗巢穴旁边。莫里斯警员拿起衣服进行了彻底检查，
examined them thoroughly, finding two booties stuck inside the feet of the jumpsuit just like Lindy Chamberlain had described dressing Azaria. He then attempted to rearrange the items the way they were found, but struggled to replicate their exact position. Unlike Wally, who believed all of the jumpsuit's press studs were undone, Constable Morris maintained two located at the crotch were fastened. Despite the significant amount of blood on the jumpsuit and singlet, there was very little damage to the clothing itself. The jumpsuit's left sleeve had a large rib and the neckline appeared to have been torn or cut, but it was otherwise intact. The singlet, which was found inside out within the jumpsuit, had two small punctures through its
发现两只小鞋塞在连体衣的脚部，就像林迪·张伯伦描述她给阿扎里娅穿衣服时那样。然后他试图将这些物品重新排列成它们被发现时的样子，但难以复制它们的确切位置。与认为连体衣所有压扣都解开的沃利不同，莫里斯警员坚称位于胯部的两个压扣是扣上的。尽管连体衣和背心上有大量的血迹，但衣服本身的损坏却非常小。连体衣的左袖有一个大撕裂，领口似乎被撕破或剪过，但其余部分完好无损。那件被发现时底朝天套在连体衣里面的背心，背部有两个小穿孔，纸尿裤也被撕破了，但没有血迹。
back, and the nappy was also torn, but contained no blood stains. There was no evidence of human tissue on any of the items. Sand, soil and plant fragments were recovered from both the outside and inside of the fabric, as well as nine animal hairs. The garments were also tested for canine saliva, but none was found. It had rained at all the routes 12 hours before the jumpsuit was discovered, allowing for the possibility that evidence had been washed away. Television networks were granted permission to broadcast images of the garments, which were shown laid out side by side. It led the public to question how a dingo could remove an infant from its clothing while leaving everything relatively intact.
没有任何物品上有存留人类组织的证据。织物的内外部都回收了沙子、土壤和植物碎片，以及九根动物毛发。还对这些服装进行了犬类唾液测试，但未发现任何唾液。在连体衣被发现前12小时，所有路线都下过雨，这使得证据被冲走的可能性存在。电视网络获得批准广播这些衣物并排铺开的图像。这引发公众质疑：野狗怎么可能在让一切相对完好的情况下将婴儿从衣服中剥离出来？
The Chamberlains learned of the discovery through news reports, and when Michael phoned Northern Territory Police, they stated their belief that the clothing belonged to Azaria. Lindy told a radio journalist that she wasn't surprised by the state of her daughter's clothes as she had previously seen dingoes attack cattle and knew what they were capable of. In a television interview, she calmly explained that dingoes used their paws like hands to peel back the skin of their prey, quote, like an orange. Some viewers were troubled by her seemingly emotionless demeanour and ability to discuss her daughter's death in such a matter-of-fact manner.
张伯伦一家通过新闻报道得知了这一发现，当迈克尔致电北领地警方时，他们表示相信这些衣物属于阿扎里娅。林迪告诉一位电台记者，她对女儿衣服的状态并不感到惊讶，因为她以前见过野狗攻击牛，并且知道它们有多大能力。在一次电视采访中，她平静地解释说，野狗像手一样用爪子剥开猎物的皮，“就像剥橘子一样”。一些观众对她看似毫无情绪的举止以及能以如此平铺直叙的方式讨论女儿的死感到不安。
Two weeks after Azaria's disappearance, Detective Sergeant Graham Charwood was appointed to lead the Chamberlain investigation, taking over from Inspector Michael Gilroy, who prepared the case's first official report to pass on to his successor. In it, he recorded a number of details that he'd uncovered when speaking to a doctor who had treated Azaria shortly before her disappearance. Writing, It is reported that Lindy appeared not to have cared for the baby and at one stage did not feed it for over eight hours. When bringing the baby in for a check-up, she astounded the sisters by having the baby dressed completely in black. A doctor who treated the baby said that she did not react like a normal mother. The same doctor said that he looked up the name
在阿扎里娅失踪两周后，侦探中士格雷厄姆·查伍德（Graham Charwood）被任命领导张伯伦案的调查，接替了迈克尔·吉尔罗伊（Michael Gilroy）督察，后者准备了该案的第一份正式报告以转交给他的继任者。他在报告中记录了他在与一位在阿扎里娅失踪前不久治疗过她的医生交谈时发现的一些细节。写道：“据报道，林迪似乎并不关心这个婴儿，甚至一度有八个多小时没有喂养她。当把婴儿带来做检查时，她把婴儿全身穿黑衣服，这让修女们大为震惊。一位治疗过这个婴儿的医生说，她的反应不像一个正常的母亲。同一位医生说，他在一本名字与含义词典中查了阿扎里娅这个名字，
Azaria in a dictionary of names and meanings and found that it means sacrifice in the wilderness. Inspector Gilroy had attempted to find this book at a library to confirm the doctor's claim, but the library's copy had been misplaced. He also noted that he had watched a television interview with the Chamberlains in which Lindy stated that the blanket covering Azaria was thick and would be difficult to cut with a knife. In contrast, Inspector Gilroy believed the rips on the blanket looked more like they had been made by a sharp instrument than canine teeth. Inspector Gilroy reported that police were unable to find any witnesses who could confirm that they had seen Azaria at all a route, but had spoken with individuals who saw Lindy holding
发现它的意思是‘荒野中的牺牲’。”吉尔罗伊督察曾试图在图书馆找到这本书以证实医生的说法，但图书馆的那本被错放了。他还指出，他看了一场对张伯伦一族的电视采访，其中林迪表示盖着阿扎里娅的毯子很厚，很难用刀割破。相比之下，吉尔罗伊督察认为毯子上的撕裂看起来更像是用锋利的工具而不是犬齿造成的。吉尔罗伊督察报告说，警方无法找到任何能够确认在任何线路上见过阿扎里娅的目击者，但与一些看到林迪将一个白色包裹抱在胸前（他们认为是一个婴儿）的人交谈过。这是警方的一个疏忽，因为他们没有记录下在阿扎里娅岩石露营地见过张伯伦一家的其他露营者的姓名和联系方式，其中许多人看到了阿扎里娅。
a white bundle against her chest, which they assumed to be a baby. This was an oversight by the police, as they had failed to take the names and contact details of the other campers who had met the Chamberlains at Azaria's rock campground, many of whom saw Azaria. He also remarked that the proximity of Azaria's clothes to Fertility Cave was noteworthy, given that the family had hiked there hours before Azaria disappeared. Consequently, he had asked Constable Morris to check the cave for any evidence of soft earth. Several days later, on Tuesday, September 2, D'Alla Springs Police announced that a coronial hearing would be heard to ascertain the fact surrounding Azaria Chamberlain's disappearance. After taking over the investigation, Detective
他还指出，鉴于一家人在阿扎里娅失踪前几个小时曾在那里徒步旅行，阿扎里娅的衣服距离生育洞很近，这一点值得注意。因此，他要求莫里斯警员检查该洞穴是否有任何松软泥土的证据。几天后的9月2日星期二，达拉泉（D'Alla Springs）警方宣布将举行死因研讯，以确定围绕阿扎里娅·张伯伦失踪的事实。接手调查后，查伍德侦探的首要行动是获取阿扎里娅失踪那个周末在阿扎里娅岩石露营地的所有汽车的登记信息。记录列出了131辆属于全澳大利亚各地人们的车辆。为了对所有人进行面谈，编制了一份问卷并转发给他们当地的警察局。
Charwood's first action was to obtain registrations for all cars that had been at Azaria's rock campground on the weekend Azaria went missing. The records listed 131 vehicles belonging to people from all over Australia. In order for all of these individuals to be interviewed, a questionnaire was compiled and forwarded to their local police stations. Police also seized a pair of Lindy Chamberlain's tracksuit pants and a sleeping bag from a dry cleaner in her home city of Mount Isa. A friend of the Chamberlains had delivered the pants there after the family returned and had shown the dry cleaner a number of stains in a spatter pattern below one knee. At a wildlife reserve in South Australia, three Dingo's were given meat encased
警方还从她家乡芒特伊萨（Mount Isa）的一家干洗店查获了一对林迪·张伯伦的运动裤和一个睡袋。张伯伦夫妇的一位朋友在他们一家回来后把裤子送到那里，并向干洗店展示了一膝盖下方呈喷溅图案的多处血迹。在南澳大利亚的一个野生动物保护区，三只野狗获得了包裹在一次性纸尿裤中的肉，以观察它们是否会以类似于阿扎里娅的方式被留下。纸尿裤被撕成了碎片，受到的破坏比阿扎里娅的严重得多。两周后在阿德莱德动物园进行了后续实验，单只野狗获得了一具穿着婴儿衣服和一次性纸尿裤的山羊尸体。
in disposable nappies to see whether they would be left in a similar manner to Azaria's. The nappies were torn to shreds and damaged far more significantly than Azaria's had been. A follow-up experiment was conducted at the Adelaide Zoo two weeks later, in which a single Dingo was given a goat carcass dressed in baby clothes and a disposable nappy. In this case, the nappy was left intact, receiving just a few perforations. The Dingo tore and chewed on the jumpsuit, but managed to extract the meat without unfastening it. On October 1, 1980, the Chamberlains were formally interviewed by Detective Char Wood. He requested that Lindy be hypnotised to help recover memories, but she refused on the basis of her religion as
在这种情况下，纸尿裤保持完好，仅受到几次穿孔。野狗撕扯并咀嚼了连体衣，但在没有解开它的情况下设法取出了肉。1980年10月1日，张伯伦夫妇接受了查伍德侦探的正式面谈。他请求对林迪进行催眠以帮助恢复记忆，但她根据自己的宗教信仰予以拒绝
she viewed hypnotism as a form of witchcraft. Regardless, Lindy was able to recount the events leading up to Azaria's disappearance in painstaking detail. She described the Dingo as being young, likely still a puppy. Unlike some of the other mangy Dingo's spotted around the campsite, this one had a shiny gold coat and fluffy ears in beautiful condition. When she first saw it, she was about halfway between the camp and the barbecue area. The Dingo was still inside the tent, but its head was exposed and it appeared to have been struggling to haul something out. It began vigorously shaking its head and Lindy thought it was carrying one of Michael's shoes by its shoelace and yelled at the Dingo to drop it and get out.
她视催眠为一种巫术。无论如何，林迪还是极其详尽地回忆了阿扎里亚失踪前发生的事情。她描述那只澳洲野犬还很年轻，可能还是一只幼犬。与营地周围发现的其他一些癞皮野犬不同，这只野犬有一层闪亮的金色皮毛和毛茸茸的耳朵，状态极佳。她第一次看到它时，她正处于营地和烧烤区之间大约一半的路程。那只野犬还在帐篷里，但它的头部露了出来，看起来它一直在费力地把什么东西拖出来。它开始剧烈地摇晃脑袋，林迪以为它叼着迈克尔的一只鞋带，便大声呵斥野犬把它放下并离开。
As Lindy turned away to alert her husband, the realisation dawned that Azaria may have been whimpering earlier because she had been attacked by the Dingo. Quote, Instinct told me that Azaria wasn't there, the dog had her, but my head told me it wasn't possible. Dingo's don't do such things, and this was just beyond the realms of reason. I could see from the door that she wasn't there, but my mind wouldn't accept it. I felt within myself that she was dead because if she was alive, I'd have heard a whimper or a cry or something, unless by some miracle she was unconscious and still alive. Lindy said the Dingo then walked toward the back of the Tarana and took off. Quote,
正当林迪转身去叫她丈夫时，她突然意识到阿扎里亚之前可能一直在呜咽，因为她遭到澳洲野犬的袭击了。引述：“直觉告诉我阿扎里亚不在那里，那只狗抓走了她，但理智告诉我这是不可能的。澳洲野犬不会做这种事，这已经超出了常理。我从门口能看到她不在那里，但我的大脑就是无法接受。我内心深处感到她已经死了，因为如果她还活着，我一定会听到呜咽声、哭声或其他什么声音，除非奇迹发生，她当时不省人事但还活着。”林迪说，那只澳洲野犬随后朝塔拉纳汽车的后部走去，然后跑开了。引述，
I couldn't tell you whether it had anything in its mouth or not. My mind refused to accept the thought that it had her in its mouth, although I knew that must be it. She confirmed the only item of Azaria's clothing that hadn't yet been recovered was her white matinee jacket with the pale lemon edging around the collar and calves. It had elastic on the sleeves and three loose buttons on the yoke and could have easily come off separately to the rest of the clothing. Lindy explained the reason she and Michael had given up on the search was because the initial shock had worn off and was replaced by the morbid reality of what they might find if Azaria was recovered. The case attracted an abundance of speculation, with rumours suggesting that the
我无法告诉你它嘴里有没有叼着东西。我的大脑拒绝接受它嘴里叼着她的想法，尽管我知道一定就是这样。她证实，阿扎里亚唯一尚未找回的衣物是她的白色短上衣，领口和裤脚周围有浅柠檬色的边缘。它的袖子上有松紧带，育克上有三个松散的纽扣，很容易与其余衣物分开脱落。林迪解释说，她和迈克尔放弃搜寻的原因是最初的震惊已经消退，取而代之的是如果找到阿扎里亚时可能会看到的残酷现实。这起案件吸引了大量的猜测，有谣言称
Chamberlains had decided to kill Azaria because she was unwell or had a disability. Others theorised that one of the Chamberlain's sons had killed Azaria and their parents concealed the crime, though this scenario was never taken seriously by police. With conjecture running rife, the Chamberlains were subjected to an increasing level of harassment. During everyday errands, they encountered strangers debating their guilt or innocence. People drove slowly past their house at night honking their car horns. Tabloid magazines ran salacious headlines such as We Didn't Kill Our Baby, while the family's faith drew severe judgement. Australians who were unfamiliar with Seventh Day Adventism incorrectly believed
张伯伦夫妇决定杀死阿扎里亚，因为她身体不适或有残疾。还有人推测张伯伦夫妇的一个儿子杀死了阿扎里亚，然后他们的父母隐瞒了罪行，尽管这种情节从未被警方认真对待。在各种猜测甚嚣尘上之际，张伯伦夫妇遭到了日益严重的骚扰。在日常办事时，他们遇到陌生人争论他们的有罪或无罪。人们在夜间缓缓开着车从他们家门前驶过，按响汽车喇叭。小报杂志登出了耸人听闻的头条新闻，例如《我们没有杀死我们的宝宝》，而该家族的信仰也招致了严厉的评判。不熟悉基督复临安息日会的澳大利亚人错误地认为
the church was tied to the People's Temple of the Disciples of Christ. Two years earlier, People's Temple leader Jim Jones ordered the mass murder of his followers at their Jonestown settlement in Guyana, as covered in episode 60 of Case File. This false connection led to speculation that Azaria had been murdered as a human sacrifice and that Lindy dressed Azaria in black in recognition of her sacrificial status. Lindy was a qualified and talented seamstress. She specialised in making custom wedding dresses and also crafted many of her own outfits. Her bold, colourful designs often drew criticism from her fellow parishioners, who felt it was inappropriate for a minister's wife to dress
该教会与人民圣殿教有联系。两年前，人民圣殿教领袖吉姆·琼斯下令在其圭亚那琼斯敦定居点屠杀追随者，正如《案卷》第60集所报道的那样。这种虚假的联系导致人们猜测阿扎里亚是被作为活人献祭而谋杀的，林迪给阿扎里亚穿黑色衣服是为了承认她作为祭品的身份。林迪是一位合格且有天赋的裁缝。她专门制作定制婚纱，还亲手制作了许多自己的服装。她大胆、色彩斑斓的设计经常引起同教派教友的批评，他们认为牧师的妻子穿得
so dramatically. Within weeks of Azaria's birth, Lindy had handcrafted or altered upwards of 30 dresses for her little girl, most of them pink. She even made replicas of some for herself so they could don matching outfits. Lindy had actually made the notorious black dress for Regan when he was a baby and Azaria had simply inherited it. On the first day Azaria wore it, Lindy dressed in a matching black and red outfit, with her daughter's dress attracting lots of attention. People seemed to have a strong reaction, either loving or hating it. The public's disdain for Lindy Chamberlain was harsh and unrelenting. She received death threats and people howled at her on the street and called her a witch. On one occasion,
如此戏剧化是不合适的。在阿扎里亚出生后的几周内，林迪已经为她的小女儿手工制作或修改了30多件连衣裙，其中大部分是粉红色的。她甚至为自己复制了其中的一些，这样他们就可以穿亲子装了。那件臭名昭著的黑色连衣裙其实是林迪在雷根还是个婴儿时为他做的，阿扎里亚只是继承了它。在阿扎里亚穿它的第一天，林迪穿了一套黑红相间的衣服，她女儿的裙子引起了极大的关注。人们似乎反应强烈，要么极其喜欢，要么深恶痛绝。公众对林迪·张伯伦的蔑视严厉而冷酷。她收到了死亡威胁，人们在街上对她嚎叫并称她为女巫。有一次，
six-year-old Aidan was walking home from school when a woman approached him and insisted he tell her the truth about what had happened to his sister. Lindy spoke out about their mistreatment in an interview, remarking, God has given us the strength to cope with Azaria's death, but going down the street, people are talking about us. She vehemently refuted the rumors that her daughter's death was anything other than a tragic accident. The coronial inquest into the disappearance of Azaria Chamberlain began in mid-December 1980, before former policeman turned coroner Dennis Barrett. Media coverage was intense, with sales of newspapers that covered proceedings increasing by roughly
六岁的艾丹正走在放学回家的路上，一个女人向他走去，坚持让他告诉她关于他姐姐到底发生了什么事的真相。林迪在一次采访中公开谈到了他们受到的虐待，她评论道：“上帝给了我们应对阿扎里亚之死的坚强力量，但走到街上，人们却在谈论我们。”她极力反驳关于她女儿的死是一场悲惨事故之外的任何其他原因的谣言。对阿扎里亚·张伯伦失踪案的验尸研讯于1980年12月中旬开始，由前警察转任的验尸官丹尼斯·巴雷特主持。媒体报道非常密集，报道案件进展的报纸销量每天大约增加
40,000 per day. The Chamberlains returned to Alice Springs to give evidence, as did a number of other witnesses who had been at Ares Rock campsite on August 17. Early on, the coroner noticed many discrepancies between first-hand accounts and initial police reports. While the latter stated that Lindy was a harsh and uncaring mother, those who had witnessed her interact with her children described the 32-year-old as tender and attentive. Despite these claims, public opinion of Lindy remained at an all-time low. Bomb threats were made to the motel where the Chamberlains were staying, and one anonymous critic phoned the court to declare,
4万份。张伯伦夫妇返回爱丽丝斯普林斯作证，8月17日在艾尔斯岩营地的许多其他证人也回到了那里作证。起初，验尸官注意到第一手陈述与最初的警方报告之间存在许多差异。虽然后者声称林迪是一个严厉且漠不关己的母亲，但那些目睹她与孩子互动的人却将这位32岁的母亲描述为温柔而体贴。尽管有这些说法，公众对林迪的看法仍然处于历史最低点。张伯伦夫妇居住的汽车旅馆接到了炸弹威胁，一名匿名批评者打电话给法院宣称：
I'm going to blow that bitch away. The true meaning of Azaria was discussed in court, with Lindy testifying that she and Michael had chosen the unique name after months of consideration because it meant, blessed by God. A Hebrew studies researcher also submitted a report to the court that dispelled the notion that Azaria meant sacrifice in the wilderness. A report submitted by biologist and dingo expert Les Harris confirmed that studies had shown dingoes were capable of carrying mammals weighing up to nine kilograms over long distances. Observations showed that a solitary dingo could consume a mammal of Azaria's weight in under 20 minutes, or even faster if mated pairs or groups
我要炸死那个贱人。法庭上讨论了阿扎里亚真正的含义，林迪作证说，她和迈克尔经过数月的考虑后选择了这个独特的名字，因为它的意思是“上帝的祝福”。一名希伯来语研究研究员还向法庭提交了一份报告，消除了阿扎里亚在荒野中献祭的概念。生物学家兼野犬专家莱斯·哈里斯提交的一份报告证实，研究表明野犬有能力将重达九公斤的哺乳动物长距离运送。观察表明，单独一只野犬可以在20分钟内吃掉一只重达阿扎里亚体重的哺乳动物，如果涉及交配对或未成熟的野犬群，
of immature dingoes were involved. Harris explained that dingoes routinely consumed their prey entirely, making it difficult to identify a location where the feed took place. He therefore concluded that if Azaria had been taken by a dingo, it was highly unlikely any trace of her body would be found more than half an hour later. Dingoes typically digest and excrete their food within 10 to 24 hours, meaning nothing could have been learned by studying the stomach contents of dingoes that were shot and killed after 8pm the day after Azaria's disappearance. Harris also said that dingoes have advanced manipulative skills and cognitive abilities. Quote, the dingo is a natural canard, in fact a wolf, not a dog, which has to practice its
速度甚至会更快。哈里斯解释说，野犬通常会把猎物整个吃掉，这使得很难确定喂食发生的位置。因此，他得出结论，如果阿扎里亚是被野犬带走的，半小时后几乎不可能找到她尸体的任何痕迹。野犬通常在10到24小时内消化并排泄食物，这意味着通过研究在阿扎里亚失踪后第二天晚上8点之后被枪杀的野犬的胃内容物，什么也学不到。哈里斯还表示，野犬具有先进的操作技能和认知能力。引述：“野犬是天然的犬科动物，实际上是狼，而不是狗，为了生存，它必须每天以极高的效率练习其
hunting skills on a daily basis and at a very high level of efficiency in order to survive. In terms of strength, speed, agility and reasoning power, they compare more readily with the natural felines, tigers, leopards, et al. It is easier to underestimate the capabilities of dingoes than to overestimate them. He described the dingoes around Uluru as particularly dangerous as they maintained their hunting skills while also being fed by tourists, resulting in a situation where they were not tame yet not wild. He dismissed any experiments conducted with dingoes at zoos and wildlife reserves as captive dingoes exhibit different behaviors from wild ones.
狩猎技能。在力量、速度、灵敏度和推理能力方面，它们更容易与自然界的猫科动物——老虎、豹子等相提并论。低估野犬的能力比高估它们更容易。”他将乌卢鲁周围的野犬描述为特别危险，因为它们在保持狩猎技能的同时还接受游客的喂养，导致它们既不驯服也不野生的状况。他驳斥了在动物园和野生动物保护区对野犬进行的任何实验，因为圈养野犬表现出与野生野犬不同的行为。
Harris's report concluded that a dingo could have taken a baby, removed its clothing and consumed it whole with ease. During the initial stages of the investigation, the chamberlain's tent was sent to Darwin for forensic testing. Blood spatter had been observed on an exterior wall, but the examining officer failed to notice the stains and placed the tent into storage without any further testing. After the inquest was well underway, the tent was finally subjected to comprehensive forensic testing. Forensic scientist Dr Andrew Scott confirmed there was a small amount of blood on the right side of the tent's exterior, consistent with arterial spray. Due to the
哈里斯的报告得出结论，野犬可以轻而易举地带走一个婴儿，脱掉她的衣服并将其整只吃掉。在调查的初期阶段，张伯伦夫妇的帐篷被送到达尔文进行法医检测。在外墙上观察到了血迹，但检查人员未能注意到这些斑点，并在没有任何进一步检测的情况下将帐篷存入了库房。验尸研讯进行得很顺利后，帐篷终于接受了全面的法医检测。法医科学家安德鲁·斯科特博士证实，帐篷外侧右侧有少量血迹，这与动脉喷血相符。由于
delay in testing the sample, he was unable to determine whether it had come from an animal or human, but was more inclined to believe it was animal blood. The inquest concluded in late February the following year. In an Australian first, Coroner Barrett allowed television news crews to share a live broadcast of his findings to quell the gossip surrounding the case. He detailed the known facts proceeding Azaria's disappearance on August 17, 1980, before concluding that she had died after being attacked by a wild dingo. Quote, In attempting to remove this babe from the tent, the dingo would have caused severe crushing to the base of the skull and neck, and lacerations to the throat and neck.
检测样品的延迟，他无法确定它是来自动物还是人类，但他更倾向于认为这是动物血。验尸研讯于次年2月下旬结束。验尸官巴雷特在澳大利亚开创了先河，允许电视新闻摄制组直播他的调查结果，以平息围绕此案的流言蜚语。他详细阐述了1980年8月17日阿扎里亚失踪前的已知事实，然后得出结论，她在遭到野生野犬袭击后死亡。引述：“在试图将这个婴儿从帐篷里拖出来时，野犬会对头骨底部和颈部造成严重的压碎伤，并对喉咙和颈部造成裂伤。
Such injuries would have resulted in swift death. Neither Lindy nor Michael Chamberlain were found responsible for their daughter's death in any way. However, the Coroner accepted the claims from police that the tears in Azaria's garments were likely caused by a sharp tool such as scissors. He put forth the possibility that a human could have interrupted the dingo as it preyed on the baby, which could explain why her clothing was relatively intact and lacked canine saliva. Barrett suggested that this unknown person may have come across Azaria while she was being attacked, scared the dingo off, and then cut off her clothing in an attempt to save her. Upon realising she was deceased, they then disposed of her body and the
这样的伤害会导致迅速死亡。林迪或迈克尔·张伯伦在任何方面都不对他们女儿的死负责。然而，验尸官接受了警方的说法，即阿扎里亚衣服上的撕裂很可能是由剪刀等锋利工具造成的。他提出了这样一种可能性：当野犬捕食婴儿时，人类可能打断了野犬，这可以解释为什么她的衣服相对完整且缺乏犬类唾液。巴雷特暗示，这个身份不明的人可能在阿扎里亚遭到袭击时偶遇了她，吓跑了野犬，然后剪掉了她的衣服以试图救她。在意识到她已经去世后，他们随后处理掉了她的尸体和
clothing. Soil and vegetation were embedded in the garment's fabric, leading the Coroner to suspect the items had been buried at some point before being retrieved and left out for a passerby to find. The Coroner critiqued conservation authorities at the Uluru Katajuta National Park for failing to take strong action after the previous dingo attacks. Remarking, this case clearly exercises that a choice has to be made between dingoes on one hand and tourism on the other. Tourists in national parks should be able to observe native fauna in its natural state, but on maintain only from a safe distance. He recommended that potentially dangerous animals such as dingoes and snakes either be enclosed or culled from popular areas of the park.
衣服。土壤和植被嵌入了服装的面料中，这让验尸官怀疑这些物品在被找回并留给路人发现之前曾在某个时候被埋葬过。验尸官批评了乌卢鲁·卡塔久塔国家公园的自然保护机构在之前的野犬袭击事件发生后未能采取强有力的行动。他评论道：“这个案子清楚地表明，必须在野犬和旅游业之间做出选择。国家公园的游客应该能够在自然状态下观察本地动物，但只能保持安全的距离。”他建议将野犬和蛇等潜在危险动物圈养起来，或者从公园的热门区域剔除。
He also criticised the Northern Territory Police Forensic Department for either not observing or not reporting the bloodstaining on the exterior of the Chamberlain's tent, which he felt certain was Azaria's. He said this failure shifted the focus of the investigation at great financial expense and caused the Chamberlain's further suffering. Addressing the family directly, he stated, To you, pastor and Mrs Chamberlain, and through you, to Aiden and Regan, may I extend my deepest sympathy. You have not only suffered the loss of your beloved child in the most tragic circumstances, but you have all been subjected to months of innuendos, suspicion, and probably the most malicious
他还批评北领地警察法医部门没有观察到或没有报告张伯伦夫妇帐篷外侧的血迹，他确信那是阿扎里亚的血迹。他说，这种失误转移了调查的焦点，造成了巨大的经济损失，并给张伯伦夫妇带来了进一步的痛苦。他直接对这一家人说：“对你们，牧师和张伯伦夫人，以及通过你们，对艾丹和雷根，我致以最深切的同情。你们不仅在最悲惨的情况下失去了心爱的孩子，而且你们所有人都遭受了数月的影射、怀疑，以及可以说是这个国家见证过的最恶毒的
gossip ever witnessed in this country. I have taken the unusual step of permitting these proceedings to be televised today in the hope that, by direct and accurate communication, such innuendos, suspicion, and gossip may cease. The Chamberlains expressed their relief at the findings outside court. They displayed a poster-sized photograph of Azaria in Lindy's arms to journalists and stated they were looking forward to starting new lives and focusing on their sons. Michael remarked, People who spread rumors have not understood the facts of the case. They will have to make peace with their God. In contrast, Northern Territory authorities were displeased by the coroner's conclusions. The Chairman of the Conservation Commission described
流言蜚语。我采取了不同寻常的步骤，允许今天的诉讼程序进行电视转播，希望通过直接和准确的沟通，这种影射、怀疑和流言蜚语能够停止。”张伯伦夫妇在法院外表达了他们对调查结果的宽慰。他们向记者展示了一张阿扎里亚在林迪怀里的大幅照片，并表示他们期待开始新的生活并专注于他们的儿子们。迈克尔评论道：“散布谣言的人没有理解案件的事实。他们必须与他们的上帝讲和。”相比之下，北领地当局对验尸官的结论感到不满。自然保护委员会主席将
his recommendations as, quote, impossible to implement, as well as being highly debatable as to its desirability. Police and prosecutors were also unhappy with the critique of their forensics unit. Several days later, a police spokesperson told the media that the case was still open but would not be investigated further, quote, unless something comes up. Later that year, British forensic scientist Professor James Cameron of the London Hospital Medical College submitted new information in relation to the Chamberlain case. Professor Cameron had previously worked as a senior forensic medicine consultant to the British Armed Forces and assisted in many high-profile investigations. He had been
他的建议描述为：“不可能实施，而且其可取性也极具争议。”警察和检察官也对对其法医部门的批评感到不满。几天后，警方发言人对媒体表示，该案仍然悬而未决，但不会进一步调查，“除非出现新情况”。同年晚些时候，伦敦医院医学院的英国法医科学家詹姆斯·卡梅隆教授提交了与张伯伦案有关的新信息。卡梅隆教授此前曾担任英国武装部队的高级法医学顾问，并协助进行了许多备受瞩目的调查。他在
unavailable during the first inquest into Azaria's disappearance, but subsequently examined her recovered clothing and determined there was an incision at the neck of her jumpsuit, which he believed was consistent with having been caused by scissors. He also found what he believed to be a small adult human handprint in the blood stains. Professor Cameron claimed there was a distinct possibility that Azaria's clothes had been buried and then later dug up and placed near the walking track to be found. He was of the opinion that a dingo was not involved in the infant's disappearance. On September 19, 1981, a year and one month after Azaria's disappearance,
对阿扎里亚失踪案的第一次验尸研讯期间无法出席，但随后检查了她找回的衣服，并确定她的连体衣领口处有一个切口，他认为这与剪刀造成的切口相符。他还发现了血迹中他认为是成年人左手小手印的痕迹。卡梅隆教授声称，阿扎里亚的衣服被埋葬然后又被挖出来放在步行道附近被人发现的可能性很大。他认为野犬没有参与这名婴儿的失踪。1981年9月19日，在阿扎里亚失踪一年零一个月后，
it was announced that the investigation was being reopened. When informed that this development was due to Professor Cameron's findings, Lindy Chamberlain responded coolly. I didn't know there were any dingo experts in London. The media frenzy was reignited, prompting Northern Territory's Chief Minister and Attorney General Paul Everingham to criticise members of the press who he believed acted like a bunch of vampires in their coverage of the story. The Chamberlain's Tarana hatchback was seized by police for forensic testing, along with various other items that had been in the tent and car on the evening of
官方宣布重新展开调查。当得知这一进展是由于卡梅隆教授的发现时，林迪·张伯伦冷淡地回应道：“我不知道伦敦有什么野犬专家。”媒体狂热再次被点燃，促使北领地首席部长兼总检察长保罗·埃弗里汉批评了那些他认为在报道这个故事时表现得像一群吸血鬼的媒体成员。张伯伦夫妇的塔拉纳掀背车被警方扣押进行法医检测，车内以及案发当晚帐篷和车内的各种其他物品也被扣押。
Azaria's disappearance. A detective examined the Tarana and found a sticky substance underneath the dashboard. Forensic investigators concluded it was likely a sugary drink or something similar, as blood would have dried within two hours of being shed. However, they later discovered what appeared to be several blood stains throughout other areas of the vehicle, including on and underneath the front passenger seat, on the interior door handles, the car's console, and a metal plate under the dashboard. The spray pattern under the dashboard was deemed to be consistent with fluid ejecting from a small orifice whilst under pressure, such as blood spray from an artery wound. Several items inside the vehicle, including a towel, Michael Chamberlain's camera
Azaria的失踪。一名侦探检查了塔拉纳，发现仪表盘下方有粘性物质。法医调查人员得出结论，它可能是一种含糖饮料或类似的东西，因为血液在流出后两小时内就会干涸。然而，他们后来发现车辆的其他区域似乎有多处血迹，包括前排乘客座椅上方和下方、车门内把手、汽车中控台以及仪表盘下的金属板。仪表盘下方的喷射图案被认为与液体在压力下从一个小孔喷出相一致，例如来自动脉伤口的血喷。车内的一些物品，包括一条毛巾、迈克尔·张伯伦的相机
bag, and a pair of nail scissors, also contained a blood-like substance. During a search of the Chamberlain's home, police also seized a small coffin that Michael had used as a prop during an anti-smoking campaign at work. Although it was dismissed as having nothing to do with Azaria's case, word of its existence got out and contributed to the ferocious rumour mill. On November 18, 1981, it was announced that based on new evidence, the findings of the previous coronial inquest had been quashed, and a new one was ordered in its place. The second inquest into Azaria Chamberlain's disappearance commenced almost a year after the first, this time before coroner Jerry Galvin. Barrister Dez Sturges acted as counsel and was
包和一把指甲剪，也含有类似血液的物质。在搜查张伯伦家时，警察还缴获了一口小棺材，迈克尔曾在工作中的反吸烟运动中将其用作道具。尽管它被认为与阿扎里亚的案子无关而被驳回，但它存在的消息还是传了出去，并助长了凶猛的谣言工厂。1981年11月18日，官方宣布根据新证据，先前验尸研讯的调查结果已被撤销，并下令进行新的研讯。对阿扎里亚·张伯伦失踪案的第二次研讯在第一次研讯近一年后开始，这次由验尸官杰里·加尔文主持。大律师德兹·斯特吉斯担任辩护律师，并
responsible for questioning witnesses. He had worked closely with the police over the previous three months and firmly believed in Lindy's guilt, with the central focus of his case being the evidence investigators had recently collated following the seizure of the Chamberlain's possessions. Biologist Joy Kuhl, who had examined the forensic evidence found in the Terana, testified that various stains had tested positive for human blood. DNA testing had not yet been developed, so she had used a screening test to check the molecular content of the blood to determine whether it belonged to an adult or an infant. She was specifically looking for Fetalhemoglobin, a protein that develops during the last
负责盘问证人。他在过去三个月里一直与警方密切合作，坚信林迪有罪，他案件的核心焦点是调查人员最近在没收张伯伦夫妇的财产后整理的证据。曾检查在特拉纳发现的法医证据的生物学家乔伊·库尔作证说，各种斑点的测试呈人血阳性。DNA检测尚未开发出来，因此她使用筛查测试来检查血液的分子含量，以确定它是属于成年人还是婴儿。她专门寻找胎儿血红蛋白，这是一种在最后
seven months in utero and persists during the first six months of life. Kuhl reported that she had found Fetalhemoglobin in 22 places throughout the Chamberlain's vehicle, as well as on Michael's camera bag and a pair of nail scissors. The blood located inside the Chamberlain's tent, which was initially presumed to have come from the Dingo attack, was confirmed to belong to Azaria. However, with the implication that she might have actually been injured in the car, the presence of blood in the tent suggested it could have been transferred there by someone else's shoes or clothing. As per standard procedure in the laboratory where she worked, Joy Kuhl destroyed the resulting
在子宫内停留七个月并在生命的前六个月持续存在。库尔报告说，她在张伯伦的车内的22个地方以及迈克尔的相机包和一把指甲剪上都发现了胎儿血红蛋白。张伯伦帐篷内发现的血迹最初被推测来自野犬袭击，后经证实属于阿扎里亚。然而，由于暗示她可能实际上是在车里受伤的，帐篷里血迹的存在表明它可能是被别人的鞋子或衣服带到那里的。按照她工作实验室的标准程序，乔伊·库尔销毁了由此产生的
plates and gels after her experiments were complete, but presented a report of her findings as evidence. When the Chamberlains first returned home following their trip to Uluru, a friend of Lindy's had taken some of their clothing to a dry cleaner. Testimony was presented in court that the friend told the dry cleaner that there were several blood stains on a pair of Lindy's tracksuit pants. The dry cleaner recalled there were approximately 36 spots on the pants from the knee to the calf. The pants had been seized by the police and taken for forensic testing, but scientists had been unable to detect any significant stains on them. Although Lindy was wearing a floral dress at the time Azaria
实验完成后放置培养皿和凝胶，但将她的调查结果报告作为证据呈交。当张伯伦夫妇结束乌卢鲁之旅首次返回家中时，林迪的一位朋友将他们的一些衣服拿到干洗店去洗。法庭上出示了证词，称这位朋友告诉干洗店，林迪的一条运动裤上有几处血迹。干洗店回忆说，裤子上从膝盖到小腿大约有36个斑点。这条裤子已被警方扣押并拿去进行法医检测，但科学家未能检测出上面有任何明显的污渍。尽管林迪在阿扎里亚失踪时穿着一件碎花连衣裙，但有人提出她可能换上了裤子，并把她的婴儿抱到汽车的乘客座位上，然后用那把指甲剪割断了她的喉咙。
went missing, it was put forward that she could have changed into the pants and taken her baby into the passenger seat of the car, where she proceeded to slit her throat using the pair of nail scissors. Forensic experts said the blood stains in the car were consistent with the child being held under the dashboard next to the passenger's feet when such an injury occurred, which would have matched the supposed blood stains on Lindy's tracksuit pants. This theory was also used to explain why similar staining hadn't occurred inside the tent. Lindy once again testified before the court. She claimed that she hadn't put the tracksuit pants on until 10pm on the night Azaria disappeared. Prior to that, they had been lying inside the
法医专家表示，车内的血迹与孩子在发生此类伤害时被抱在乘客脚旁的仪表盘下方是一致的，这与林迪运动裤上所谓的血迹相吻合。这一理论也被用来解释为什么车内没有出现类似的血迹。帐篷。林迪再次出庭作证。她声称，直到阿扎里亚失踪当晚10点，她才穿上那条运动裤。在此之前，它们一直躺在帐篷里
tent near its entry. She denied that there was any blood on them or ever telling her friend that they were stained with blood. As for the blood in the vehicle, Michael said he was uncertain how it came to be there. The chamberlains had purchased the car almost the brand new in December 1977, and since taking ownership, both of their sons had previously suffered nosebleeds in the car. On one occasion, they had also picked up a hitchhiker who was bleeding following a traffic accident. The inquest was adjourned over the Christmas holiday period, and when it resumed on February 1, 1982, Barrister Des Sturges told the coroner that there was sufficient evidence to prove that Lindy Chamberlain had cut her daughter's throat, and that her husband had been an accessory
帐篷靠近入口处。她否认上面有血，也否认曾告诉她的朋友上面沾有血迹。至于车内的血迹，迈克尔表示他不确定它是怎么弄上去的。张伯伦夫妇在1977年12月买下这辆车时几乎是全新的，自从拥有它以来，他们的两个儿子以前都在车里流过鼻血。有一次，他们还顺便载过一个在交通事故后流血的搭车客。研讯在圣诞节假期期间休会，当它于1982年2月1日复会时，大律师德兹·斯特吉斯告诉验尸官，有足够的证据证明林迪·张伯伦割断了她女儿的喉咙，而且她丈夫是她罪行的
to her crime. The next day, coroner Galvin told the courtroom that while the evidence was largely circumstantial, he believed a properly instructed jury could arrive at a verdict. He then formally charged Lindy Chamberlain with the murder of her nine-week-old daughter. Michael Chamberlain was charged with being an accessory after the fact. The couple remained silent and stoic as the news was delivered. To avoid prejudicing any future juries, coroner Galvin chose not to share his full findings with the public. Later that month, he sent a letter marked private and confidential to Crown Prosecutor Peter Tiffin, in which he outlined the evidence and stated his opinions.
同谋。第二天，验尸官加尔文在法庭上表示，尽管证据大多是间接的，但他相信经过适当指导的陪审团可以得出裁决。随后，他正式指控林迪·张伯伦谋杀她九周大的女儿。迈克尔·张伯伦被指控为事后窝藏罪犯。宣读消息时，这对夫妇保持沉默且坚决。为了避免对任何未来的陪审团产生偏见，验尸官加尔文选择不向公众公开他的完整调查结果。当月晚些时候，他向皇家检察官彼得·蒂芬发送了一封标有私人和机密的信件，在信中他概述了证据并阐明了他的意见。
He agreed that a dingo was not responsible for Azaria's death, accepting that bloodstaining on the infant's jumpsuit was indicative of her being held by an adult as the act of killing was carried out. He also believed Azaria had likely been buried while still wearing her clothing. While he agreed that the smaller indentations in her clothing were consistent with animal teeth marks, he was convinced that the garments had been cut and torn by a person, and that the jumpsuit's collar had been cut after the bloodstaining had already occurred. As the clothing wasn't strewn about, coroner Galvin found this was inconsistent with an animal being responsible for their positioning. He concluded,
他同意野犬不对阿扎里亚的死负责，并接受婴儿连体衣上的血迹表明她在行凶时被一个成年人抱着。他还认为阿扎里亚可能在还穿着衣服的时候就被埋葬了。虽然他同意她衣服上较小的凹痕与动物牙齿的印记一致，但他确信这些衣服是由人切割和撕裂的，并且连体衣的领子是在血迹已经出现后才被剪掉的。由于衣服没有散落各处，验尸官发现这与动物对其定位负责不一致。他总结道：
I find Azaria Chamberlain came to her death at Air's Rock on August 17, 1980. Cause of death was extensive and fatal wound or wounds to the neck. He dispelled the rumours that one of Azaria's siblings could have been responsible, by confirming that there was no evidence linking Aidan or Regan to her death in any way. While acknowledging that there was no apparent motive for the murder, and that witnesses described to Lindy's relationship with Azaria positively, coroner Galvin stated, quote, the killing of a child by a mother is not an uncommon happening. Lindy and Michael Chamberlain pleaded not guilty to the charges and were released pending trial
我发现阿扎里亚·张伯伦于1980年8月17日在艾尔斯岩去世。死因是颈部广泛且致命的伤口。他通过证实没有任何证据将艾丹或雷根与她的死亡联系起来，消除了有关阿扎里亚的一个兄弟姐妹可能负有责任的谣言。在承认谋杀没有明显的动机，并且证人对林迪与阿扎里亚的关系进行了积极的描述的同时，验尸官加尔文说：“引述，母亲杀害孩子并不是不常见的事情。”林迪和迈克尔·张伯伦对指控做出了无罪抗辩，并在等待审判期间以
and a collective bail of $10,000. In the interim, the Australian media took to broadcasting old controversial interviews with the couple while openly debating their guilt. One radio station concluded a segment by stating, when the trial goes to court, the world might find out just why Lindy Chamberlain cut the throat of her tiny daughter. Barrister Dez Sturgis, who was of the opinion that Lindy was guilty, expressed his disappointment in the media's conduct as it compromised the likelihood of finding an impartial jury for the high-profile case. Three months before the trial commenced, news broke that Lindy was pregnant. Friends of the Chamberlains told the press that the couple were delighted and were praying the
10,000美元的集体保释金被释放。在此期间，澳大利亚媒体播放了这对夫妇过去有争议的采访，同时公开辩论他们的有罪与否。一家广播电台在结束一个片段时说：“当审判上法庭时，世界可能会发现为什么林迪·张伯伦要割断她幼小女儿的喉咙。”大律师德兹·斯特吉斯认为林迪有罪，他对媒体的行为表示失望，因为这损害了在这个备受瞩目的案件中找到公正陪审团的可能性。在审判开始前三个月，有消息传出林迪怀孕了。张伯伦夫妇的朋友告诉媒体，这对夫妇欣喜若狂，并祈祷
baby would be a girl. By the time the Chamberlains trial began in Darwin's Supreme Court on Monday, September 13, 1982, Lindy was seven months pregnant. It had been just over two years since Azaria went missing, although the media seemed far more interested in Lindy's unborn child, with reports focusing on the wide range of maternity dresses she wore to court. The trial was presided over by Justice James Muirhead, with 12 Northern Territory residents selected from a panel of 123 potential jurors. Despite the Northern Territory having a higher population of Indigenous residents, all the jurors work occasion. Crown Prosecutor Ian Barker told the court that the key evidence in the form of Azaria's jumpsuit
是个女孩。当张伯伦夫妇的审判于1982年9月13日星期一在达尔文最高法院开始时，林迪已经怀孕七个月了。距离阿扎里亚失踪已经过去了两年多，尽管媒体似乎对林迪未出生的孩子更感兴趣，报道主要集中在她穿去法庭的各种孕妇装上。审判由法官詹姆斯·缪尔黑德主持，12名北领地居民从123名潜在陪审团成员中选出。尽管北领地原住民居民比例较高，但所有陪审团成员都在工作。皇家检察官伊恩·巴克告诉法庭，以阿扎里亚连体衣形式出现的关键证据
and the fetal hemoglobin stains found on the front seat of the car would prove that, quote, the dingo story was a fanciful lie, calculated to conceal the truth, which is that the child Azaria died by her mother's hand. The prosecution's stance was that during the time Lindy said she was putting Azaria to bed, she had actually taken her into the front seat of the Tarana and slit her throat using a pair of scissors. She then stored the body in her husband's camera case that was stashed below the front seat. They alleged that Lindy concocted the story about the dingo, and while everyone was out searching for the animal, she and Michael disposed of Azaria's body.
以及在前排座椅上发现的胎儿血红蛋白污渍将证明，“引述，野犬的故事是一个虚构的谎言，旨在掩盖真相，即儿童阿扎里亚死于她母亲之手。”控方的立场是，在林迪说她正在哄阿扎里亚睡觉的这段时间里，她实际上把她抱到了塔拉纳的前排座椅上，并用一把剪刀割断了她的喉咙。然后她把尸体藏在前排座椅下方的丈夫的相机包里。他们声称林迪捏造了关于野犬的故事，当大家都在寻找这只动物时，她和迈克尔处理掉了阿扎里亚的尸体。
Barker played on the popular opinion that dingoes didn't attack babies, and highlighted that there had been no official documented reports of one ever taking and killing a child. Various authorities were called to support the prosecution's theory, including several forensic and textile experts who gave evidence that the damage to Azaria's jumpsuit was caused by cutting. Professor James Cameron, who had submitted the report that resulted in the case being reopened, presented images of Azaria's clothing taken under ultraviolet light, which he believed showed a pattern consistent with the bloody right handprint of a small adult. London-based odontologist Bernard Sims, who had investigated two dozen dog attacks on humans,
巴克利用了野犬不攻击婴儿的流行观点，并强调没有官方记录表明野犬曾抓走并杀死过儿童。各方权威被召集来支持控方的理论，包括几位法医和纺织品专家，他们作证说阿扎里亚连体衣的损坏是由于切割造成的。提交了导致案件重新审理的报告的詹姆斯·卡梅隆教授展示了在紫外线灯下拍摄的阿扎里亚衣服的照片，他认为这些照片显示了与一个成年人血淋淋的右手印相一致的图案。伦敦牙医学专家伯纳德·斯ims调查了二十多起狗袭击人类的事件，
said the blood stains on Azaria's clothing were not consistent with the dingo attack, as such an incident would cause far more copious bleeding. He also said a baby's head was too big to fit into a dingo's jaws. The prosecution's argument also relied heavily on their assertion that no dingo hairs had been found in the chamberlain's tent or on Azaria's recovered clothing. The nine animal hairs from one of Azaria's blankets, which were initially believed to be dingo hairs, were later identified as belonging to a cat. The blood evidence compiled by forensic biologist Joy Kuhl was used by the prosecution to assert that Azaria had been murdered inside the chamberlain's terrana. They argued that the blood appeared to flow in a pattern consistent
表示阿扎里亚衣服上的血迹与野犬袭击不符，因为这样的事件会导致更多大量的出血。他还表示，婴儿的头部太大，无法放进野犬的嘴里。控方的论点还严重依赖于他们的断言，即在张伯伦的帐篷里或阿扎里亚找回的衣服上没有发现野犬毛发。阿扎里亚的一条毯子上的九根动物毛发最初被认为是野犬毛发，后来被鉴定为属于一只猫。控方利用法医生物学家乔伊·库尔汇编的血液证据断言阿扎里亚是在张伯伦的特拉纳内部被谋杀的。他们认为，血流的图案与
with someone bleeding while sitting in the front passenger seat, which ruled out the possibility it had been caused by the injured hitchhiker the chamberlains had previously picked up, as he had been lying in the backseat. Although the blood samples had since been destroyed, Kuhl's direct supervisor, Dr. Simon Baxter, testified to seeing the plates and gels used in her experiments and agreed with her findings. Other experts who had read over Kuhl's laboratory reports also approved of the methods she used and the conclusions she derived. The defense argued that Azaria's death was nothing more than a tragic accident. Two professors of biology took the stand to debunk the prosecution's blood findings,
有人坐在前排乘客座位上时流血的情况相符，这排除了它是被张伯伦之前接载的受伤搭车客造成的可能性，因为他一直躺在后座上。尽管血液样本此后已被销毁，但库尔的直接上司西蒙·巴克斯特博士作证说，他看到了她的实验中使用的培养皿和凝胶，并同意她的发现。其他阅读过库尔实验室报告的专家也认可了她使用的方法和她得出的结论。辩护方辩称，阿扎里亚的死不过是一场悲惨的事故。两位生物学教授出庭反驳控方的血液发现，
arguing that Kuhl's testing methods could have produced false positives for fetal hemoglobin, and the bloodstains could have come from a number of sources over the years. In response to Bernard Sims' claim that a dingo couldn't carry a human infant, defense lawyer Andrew Kirkham presented a photo of a dingo successfully holding a baby-sized the doll by the crown of its head, its canine teeth extending to the doll's ears. Upon seeing the photo, Sims conceded that his earlier statement might have been incorrect. In favor of the defense, Dr. H.J. Orems, an expert in dental medicine and surgery from the University of Melbourne, testified that the damage to Azaria's jumpsuit was consistent with
认为库尔的测试方法可能对胎儿血红蛋白产生假阳性结果，并且血迹多年来可能来自多种来源。针对伯纳德·斯ims关于野犬无法搬运人类婴儿的说法，辩护律师安德鲁·柯克姆出示了一张野犬成功用犬齿叼住一个婴儿大小的娃娃的头顶，其犬齿延伸到娃娃耳朵的照片。看到照片后，斯ims承认他早先的说法可能不正确。为了辩护方的利益，墨尔本大学牙科医学和外科专家H.J.奥雷姆斯博士作证说，阿扎里亚连体衣的损坏与
dingo teeth, which have a scissor-like action. The defense also worked to discredit Professor James Cameron by highlighting another high-profile criminal case he had been involved in. In 1972, he had testified against three men who were being tried for the London murder of 26-year-old Maxwell Confaith. In favor of the prosecution, Professor Cameron provided an estimated time of death that was crucial to the case. The defendants were convicted, but were later proven innocent, with Professor Cameron's evidence dismissed as incorrect. Various eyewitnesses who were at Air's Rock campsite on the night of Azaria's disappearance were called to the stand, including Sally Lowe, who had been chatting with the chamberlains at
具有剪刀状动作的野犬牙齿一致。辩护方还通过强调詹姆斯·卡梅隆教授参与的另一起备受瞩目的刑事案件来抹黑他。1972年，他曾出庭指证三名因谋杀26岁的麦克斯韦·康费斯而在伦敦受审的男子。为了支持控方，卡梅隆教授提供了一个对案件至关重要的估计死亡时间。被告被定罪，但后来被证明是无罪的，卡梅隆教授的证据被驳回为不正确。阿扎里亚失踪当晚在艾尔斯岩营地的多名目击者被传唤出庭，其中包括萨莉·洛，当林迪拉响警报时，她一直在
the barbecue area when Lindy raised the alarm. Sally testified that when Lindy put Azaria to bed, which was the time period the prosecution alleged she had been murdered, she was absent for between six and ten minutes. When she returned, Sally heard a baby's cry coming from the chamberlain's tent, which prompted Lindy to check on Azaria and interrupt the dingo. Ranger Derrick Roth gave evidence of having seen dingo tracks leading away from the chamberlains tent, as well as what appeared to be the impression of a knitted material in the nearby sand dunes, consistent with the fabric of the matinee jacket Azaria had been wearing. Fellow camper Amy Whittaker testified that when the initial search for Azaria was underway,
烧烤区与张伯伦夫妇聊天。萨莉作证说，当林迪让阿扎里亚睡觉时——也就是控方指控她被谋杀的时间段——她离开了六到十分钟。当她回来时，萨莉听到从张伯伦的帐篷里传出婴儿的哭声，这促使林迪去查看阿扎里亚并打断了野犬。护林员德里克·罗斯作证说，他看到野犬的足迹通向张伯伦的帐篷，以及附近沙丘上似乎是针织材料的印记，这与阿扎里亚一直穿的短上衣的面料相符。同行的露营者艾米·惠特克作证说，当对阿扎里亚的最初搜寻正在进行时，
Lindy and Michael walked off into the bush for between 15 and 20 minutes. The prosecution used her testimony to argue that the chamberlains had taken this time to bury Azaria, but Amy stated she was the one who suggested that the couple take the walk together. Wally Goodwin, who had found Azaria's clothing, also appeared before the court. He criticized the investigators' handling of the garments, stating that their photographs taken at the scene were nothing like the way the clothing was found. Lindy Chamberlain openly wept on the stand as images of her daughter's blood-stained clothing were displayed. Her lawyer asked her to hold her hand against the alleged bloody handprint
林迪和迈克尔走进丛林呆了15到20分钟。控方利用她的证词辩称张伯伦夫妇利用这段时间埋葬了阿扎里亚，但艾米表示是她建议这对夫妇一起散步的。找到阿扎里亚衣服的沃利·古德温也出庭作证。他批评调查人员对服装的处理，称他们在现场拍摄的照片与衣服被发现的方式完全不像。当展示她女儿沾满鲜血的衣服的照片时，林迪·张伯伦在证人席上公开痛哭。她的律师要求她将手放在卡梅隆教授声称在衣服上识别出的血手印上。
that Professor Cameron claimed to have identified on the garment. Not only was Lindy's index finger too long to match the print, but it also appeared to show four phalange bones, while human fingers possess only three. During extensive cross-examination, the prosecution challenged Lindy's statement that Azaria had been wearing a matinee jacket on the night in question. Responding officer Constable Frank Morris said he had no recollection of Lindy mentioning the jacket when her baby was reported missing. They focused on the blood evidence, with Lindy maintaining her previous explanations for how it may have come to be in the vehicle,
不仅林迪的食指太长而无法与指纹相匹配，而且它似乎还显示出四块指骨，而人类的手指只有三块。在广泛的盘问中，控方对林迪关于阿扎里亚在事发当晚穿了一件短上衣的陈述提出了质疑。回应的警官弗兰克·莫里斯表示，当她的婴儿被报告失踪时，他根本不记得林迪提到过这件短上衣。他们将重点放在血液证据上，林迪坚持她先前对血液如何进入车内的解释。
adding that Michael often stopped to help roadside traffic victims and may have trailed some of their blood into the car. On the stand, Michael Chamberlain was quizzed about why he had described his daughter's death as the will of God. He said he couldn't recall making the comment, but as a religious man, he believed that God's will is overall. The trial became the most publicized court case in Australian history and was dubbed the Trial of the Century. As it reached its conclusion, prosecutor Ian Barker appealed to the jury's identity as Northern Territorians,
并补充说，迈克尔经常停下来帮助路上的交通受害者，可能把他们的一些血迹带入了车内。在证人席上，迈克尔·张伯伦被盘问，为什么他把女儿的死描述为上帝的旨意。他说他不记得自己说过这话，但作为一个有宗教信仰的人，他相信上帝的旨意是一切的主宰。这场审判成为澳大利亚历史上最受瞩目的法庭案件，并被称为“世纪审判”。随着审判接近尾声，检察官伊恩·巴克向陪审团诉诸北领地居民的身份认同，
telling them that they knew Dingoes didn't kill human babies. An ABC news article later interpreted this statement by saying, Mr Barker QC could have easily been sitting around a Darwin barbecue with a beer in his hand talking to locals, talking about some crazy idea about Dingoes that Southerners, people from out of town, had dreamt up. In summing up his case, Barker acknowledged that the prosecution had no motive for Lindy's alleged crime, but stated it was simply their job to prove that a murder had been committed. And that, I respectfully submit, is what has been proved.
告诉他们，他们很清楚野狗不会杀死人类婴儿。澳大利亚广播公司（ABC）的一篇新闻文章后来对这段话进行了解释，称巴克皇家大律师当时完全可以手里拿着啤酒，坐在达尔文的烧烤聚会上，跟当地人聊天，谈论那些南方人、外地人幻想出来的关于野狗的疯狂想法。在做案情总结时，巴克承认检方找不到林迪涉嫌犯罪的动机，但表示他们的职责只是证明谋杀案确实发生了。他恭敬地表示，这一点已经得到了证明。
In his closing address for the defense, John Phillips described the scenario's outline by the prosecution as laughable. He stated that while prosecutors were not obligated to prove a motive, the defense had shown that Lindy Chamberlain was a doting mother who had not suffered from post-natal depression or any other disorder that would lead her to harm her child. Before the jury retired to deliberate, Justice Muirhead clarified that the defense was not challenging the fact that blood was found in the Chamberlain's terrana, but simply questioning whether the tests had accurately proved it contained fetal hemoglobin.
约翰·菲利普斯在为辩方做总结陈词时，将检方勾勒的案情斥为荒谬。他指出，虽然检察官没有义务证明动机，但辩方已经证明，林迪·张伯伦是一位慈爱的母亲，她没有患过产后抑郁症或其他会导致她伤害孩子的疾病。在陪审团退庭商议之前，缪尔黑德法官澄清说，辩方并没有对张伯伦夫妇的越野车中发现血迹这一事实提出异议，而只是质疑这些测试是否准确地证明了其中含有胎儿血红蛋白。
He urged the jury to be mindful that the blood could have come from a number of sources, and it was not the Chamberlain's burden to prove how it came to be there. He also instructed the jury to remember that Sully Lowe had testified to hearing a baby's cry coming from the Chamberlain's tent, and if this was true, it disproved the prosecution's claim that Azaria had already been murdered by that time. The jury deliberated for six and a half hours before delivering their verdict on October 29, 1982. Both Lindy and Michael Chamberlain were found guilty. A reporter from the Sydney Morning Herald newspaper who had been following the proceedings
他敦促陪审团注意，血迹可能来自多种来源，证明血迹是如何出现在那里的并不是张伯伦夫妇的责任。他还指示陪审团记住，萨莉·洛曾作证说听到张伯伦夫妇的帐篷里传出婴儿的哭声，如果这是真的，这就推翻了检方关于阿扎里亚在那之前已经被谋杀的说法。陪审团商议了六个半小时，于1982年10月29日做出了裁决。林迪和迈克尔·张伯伦均被判有罪。《悉尼先驱晨报》的一名记者一直在关注庭审过程，
leapt to his feed-in shock and yelled, Bastards, Lindy showed no emotion as the verdict was read, while Michael appeared strained, biting his lip. Just as Muirhead sentenced Michael to an 18-month suspended sentence with a good behavior bond, he told Lindy, who is now eight months pregnant, quote, You have been found guilty of murder by verdict of a jury. There is only one sentence I can pass on you. That sentence is you will be imprisoned with hard labor for life. Lindy Chamberlain was sent to serve her life sentence at the maximum security barama prison in Darwin, where she was one of only six female linmates.
他震惊得跳了起来，大喊道：“这群混蛋！”宣读判决时，林迪没有流露出任何情绪，而迈克尔则显得很紧张，咬着嘴唇。就在缪尔黑德判处迈克尔18个月监禁、缓期执行并需遵守良好行为保证时，他对当时怀有八个月身孕的林迪说：“根据陪审团的裁决，你已被判谋杀罪名成立。我只能对你判处一种刑罚。那就是判处你终身监禁并进行苦役。”林迪·张伯伦被送往达尔文市戒备森严的巴里马监狱服无期徒刑，那里只有另外五名女性囚犯。
On November 17, 1982, three weeks after her conviction, Lindy gave birth to a baby girl. To prevent the media from speculating over the meaning behind their newborn daughter's name, as they had done with Azaria, the Chamberlains made up her name, Carlia. Lindy reportedly commented, Let them try to make something out of that. The Chamberlains appealed their convictions on various grounds, and two days after Carlia's birth, Lindy was granted bail pending the results of her appeal. She was permitted to live at the Avondale College Center, a seventh-day Adventist church education facility on the New South Wales Central Coast, where Michael was residing with their sons.
1982年11月17日，在她被定罪三周后，林迪生下了一个女婴。为了防止媒体像对阿扎里亚那样，去揣测他们新生女儿名字背后的含义，张伯伦夫妇自己编了一个名字——卡莉娅。据报道，林迪评论说：“让他们去琢磨去吧。”张伯伦夫妇以各种理由对他们的定罪提出上诉，在卡莉娅出生两天后，林迪获得保释，等待上诉结果。她被允许住在阿文代尔学院中心，这是新南威尔士州中部海岸的一所基督复临安息日会教堂教育设施，迈克尔和他们的儿子们当时就住在那里。
It was a self-sufficient community in a secluded wooded area, with approximately 60 teaching staff, 40 ancillary employees, and 530 students, many of whom lived on site. Lindy's limited release outraged members of the public. In a letter to the editor published in the Sydney Morning Herald, one angry citizen wrote, So much for a fair trial. Why waste all those thousands of taxpayers' dollars for two coronial inquests and one trial by judge and jury, and to then allow Mrs Chamberlain bail pending appeal? Our pity must surely go to the convicted persons still in our jails who do not have the support of a church or religious institutions. Why should Lindy Chamberlain be given special
这是一个位于偏僻林区的自给自足的社区，大约有 60 名教职员工、40 名后勤员工和 530 名学生，其中许多人住在校内。林迪的有条件获释激怒了公众。在《悉尼先驱晨报》发表的一封致编辑的信中，一位愤怒的市民写道：“公平审判就到此为止吧。为什么要浪费纳税人成千上万的资金进行两次死因研讯和一次由法官和陪审团进行的审判，然后又允许张伯伦太太保释等待上诉？我们的同情肯定应该给予那些仍然在我们的监狱里、没有教堂或宗教机构支持的被定罪的人。凭什么林迪·张伯伦能得到特殊的
privileges merely because she has had a new baby? One indignant citizen called Lindy an actress and questioned why she could escape a murder conviction while he couldn't get off a traffic fine. Another asked, What sort of berry land are we living in? Meanwhile, the seventh-day Adventists were vilified for their association with the Chamberlains. One church in Melbourne was splashed with red paint, and red paw prints were painted on the footpath leading to its door. In Sydney, a group of Adventist teenagers were chased down the street by a woman who accused them of being child killers. On the New South Wales Central Coast, a sign was placed at the front of one Adventist church which read,
特权，仅仅因为她生了一个新孩子？”另一位愤怒的市民称林迪为“女演员”，并质疑为什么她能逃脱谋杀罪名，而他却无法免除交通罚单。还有人问：“我们到底生活在什么荒谬的国度里？”与此同时，基督复临安息日会因与张伯伦夫妇的关联而遭到恶毒攻击。墨尔本的一座教堂被泼了红漆，通往大门的步行道上被画上了红色的爪印。在悉尼，一群安息日会的青少年在街上被一个女人追赶，她指责他们是杀婴凶手。在新南威尔士州中部海岸，一个安息日会教堂的前面挂着一块牌子，上面写着：
dingo pops for sale, apply within. The hostility only worsened when Lindy told the press that the church had agreed to be guarantor on loans she and Michael had taken out to pay their legal fees, which totaled three quarters of a million dollars. The Chamberlains appealed their convictions to the federal court on 23 different grounds, disputing that the trial judge misdirected the jury in multiple instances and shouldn't have admitted evidence given by certain witnesses. On April 29, 1983, three appellate judges in Sydney unanimously rejected the couple's appeal on all grounds, stating that the jury had been entitled to draw its own conclusions from the evidence presented. Michael held back tears as Lindy kept her gaze to the floor. She was returned
“出售野狗冰棒，请在内洽询”。当林迪向媒体透露，教堂已同意为她和迈克尔为支付高达75万美元的律师费而获得贷款提供担保时，这种敌意更加恶化了。张伯伦夫妇以23种不同的理由向联邦法院对他们的定罪提出上诉，辩称主审法官在多个实例中对陪审团进行了错误指导，并且不应采纳某些证人提供的证据。1983年4月29日，悉尼的三名上诉法官一致驳回了这对夫妇的上诉，所有理由均不成立，并表示陪审团有权根据提交的证据得出自己的结论。迈克尔强忍着泪水，而林迪则把目光投向地板。她被送回了
to Berrima Prison in Darwin. The federal court ruling was a source of disappointment for those who supported or sympathized with the Chamberlains. They expressed their compassion and opinions in letters that were published in major publications, prompting legal academics to request they be banned out of respect for the country's legal system. At Berrima, Lindy was so inundated with mail from supporters that the prison facilities struggled to keep up with the influx. To show her appreciation, she started writing a monthly bulletin that was sent out to hundreds of subscribers. In November, the Chamberlains appealed their convictions to the High Court of Australia. Three months later, on February 22, 1984, on a vote of three judges against two,
达尔文的巴里马监狱。联邦法院的裁决让那些支持或同情张伯伦夫妇的人感到失望。他们在各大刊物发表的信件中表达了他们的同情和看法，促使法律学者出于对国家法律体系的尊重，要求禁止发表此类信件。在巴里马，林迪收到了大量支持者的来信，以至于监狱设施都难以应付源源不断的信件。为了表达谢意，她开始撰写一份月度简报，发给数百名订阅者。11月，张伯伦夫妇向澳大利亚高等法院对他们的定罪提出上诉。三个月后，即1984年2月22日，经过三名法官对两名法官的投票表决，
their appeal was again dismissed and both Lindy and Michael's convictions upheld. Shortly after, Michael announced he was resigning as an ordained minister with the Seventh Day Adventist Church, later telling the media, God will come to my aid. I'm just wondering why it's taking him so long. In one edition of her monthly bulletin, Lindy wrote, The total effect of the last four years on the lives of myself and my family are permanent and far-reaching. No one who has been touched by our tragedy and the subsequent events can claim to have been unaffected. I don't cry myself to sleep much anymore. I just grit my teeth determinedly. Although I've felt broken at times, with God's help I've risen, armed for the fight.
他们的上诉再次被驳回，林迪和迈克尔的定罪均维持不变。不久之后，迈克尔宣布辞去基督复临安息日会按立牧师的职务，后来他对媒体说：“上帝会来帮我的。我只是想知道为什么他花了这么长时间。”在其中一期月度简报中，林迪写道：“过去四年对我和我家人的生活造成的整体影响是持久且深远的。任何受到我们的悲剧及随后的事件影响的人，都无法宣称自己没有受到影响。我不再怎么哭着入睡了。我只是坚定地咬紧牙关。尽管有时我感到心碎，但在上帝的帮助下，我已经站起来，武装好自己准备战斗。”
Others haven't been so lucky. Lindy occupied her time in custody with crafts, leatherwork, and weaving. She made belts for her sons, winter outfits for Kalia, and a tapestry for Aidan's bedroom. She composed a poem for Azaria, which read, Not a day has ended with the fading of the light that I have not remembered you, Azaria. Good night. When Azaria went missing, Uluru Park Ranger Derrick Roth recalled an incident eight weeks prior in which a dingo grabbed a three-year-old girl by the head and dragged her from a car. The Chamberlain's defense team had attempted to locate the girl's family to provide evidence at trial, but were
其他人就没有那么幸运了。林迪在羁押期间通过手工艺、皮革制品和编织来打发时间。她为儿子们制作皮带，为卡莉娅制作冬装，还为艾丹的卧室制作了一幅挂毯。她为阿扎里亚写了一首诗，上面写着：“没有一天在光芒渐逝中结束时，我不曾想起你，阿扎里亚。晚安。”阿扎里亚失踪时，乌鲁鲁公园护林员德里克·罗斯回忆起八周前发生的一起事件：一只野狗抓住了一个三岁小女孩的头部，把她从车里拖了出来。张伯伦夫妇的辩护团队曾试图找到这个女孩的家人以便在审判中提供证据，但
unable to do so. In early 1984, the family finally came forward and confirmed the events. As a result, Ranger Roth penned a letter that was published in the National Times newspaper, calling for an inquiry into the evidence presented at the Chamberlain's trial. It read, Since the incident of Azaria's disappearance, I have heard dingo experts stating that a dingo would not enter tents or attack humans whether adult or juvenile. Having lived at Erzrock for 16 years, I know that the dingoes of this area are conditioned by and to the people. Consequently, their behavior is not that of a true wild animal and not fully understood by anyone. I have no doubt that a dingo is capable of attacking children and the possibility of a
未能找到。1984年初，这家人终于现身并证实了这些事件。因此，罗斯护林员写了一封信，发表在《国家时报》上，呼吁对张伯伦夫妇审判中提交的证据进行调查。信中写道：“自从阿扎里亚失踪事件发生以来，我听到野狗专家称，无论是成年还是幼年野狗，都不会进入帐篷或攻击人类。在艾尔斯岩生活了16年，我知道该地区的野狗已经被人驯化并适应了人类。因此，它们的行为与真正的野生动物不同，并没有被任何人完全理解。我毫不怀疑野狗有能力攻击儿童，因此野狗叼走婴儿的可能性是完全可行的。我认为我们任何人都无法对现状感到安心。”
dingo carrying away a baby is therefore quite feasible. I do not think any of us should feel comfortable with the present situation. In response, 31 scientists signed an open letter protesting the conclusions reached by forensic biologist Joy Kuhl. They challenged her assertions that fetal blood had been found in the Chamberlain's vehicle. A public poll revealed 53% of Australians still believed Lindy was guilty, but on May 3, a petition signed by 131,000 individuals in favour of releasing her from prison was presented to the Governor-General. The Chamberlain's lawyer Stuart Tipple had been retained by Lindy and Michael after the first coronal inquest in 1981, and he had represented them in all legal proceedings since. As one of their most vocal
作为回应，31名科学家签署了一封公开信，抗议法医生物学家乔伊·库尔得出的结论。他们质疑她关于在张伯伦夫妇的车里发现胎儿血液的断言。一项民意调查显示，53%的澳大利亚人仍然认为林迪有罪，但在5月3日，一份由131,000名支持释放她的个人签名的请愿书被呈交给总督。张伯伦夫妇的律师斯图尔特·蒂普尔是在1981年第一次死因研讯后被林迪和迈克尔聘用的，此后他一直代表他们参与所有的法律程序。作为他们最直言不讳的
supporters, in June of 1985, Stuart supervised a media campaign which led to the creation of the Chamberlain Innocence Committee. The group featured many prominent members of society who called for the Northern Territory Government to launch a royal commission into the case. They submitted a 40-page document titled The Blue Book, which contained new evidence gathered by Stuart's forensic team, along with an application for a full judicial inquiry into the case. The Blue Book debunked the prosecution's claim that the carts on Azaria's clothing had been made using scissors. It detailed the studies of an associate professor in textile sciences at Kansas State University who examined infant garments that had been chewed on by a dingo.
支持者之一，1985年6月，斯图尔特监督了一场媒体运动，促成了“张伯伦清白委员会”的成立。该小组成员众多，汇集了许多社会名流，他们呼吁北领地政府对该案展开皇家调查委员会的调查。他们提交了一份长达40页、名为《蓝皮书》的文件，其中包含斯图尔特的法医团队收集的新证据，以及对该案进行全面司法调查的申请。《蓝皮书》驳斥了检方关于阿扎里亚衣服上的裂口是用剪刀剪出来的说法。其中详细介绍了堪萨斯州立大学纺织科学副教授的研究，他检查了曾被野狗啃咬过的婴儿服装。
They displayed neatly sliced carts, consistent with the ones on Azaria's clothing. The prosecution also claimed the nine animal hairs found on Azaria's clothing had come from a cat. The Blue Book clarified that research conducted at the Turnbull Institute in Melbourne concluded two of the hairs were human, one was inconclusive, and the remaining six were canine. Another report showed that one of the stains in the Chamberlain's vehicle that the prosecution argued was bloodspray from Azaria's neck wound was actually a combination of a sticky beverage and soundproofing paint used during the manufacture of the vehicle. During the trial, Joy Kuhl had submitted reports explaining how she conducted examinations on
它们呈现出整齐切开的裂口，与阿扎里亚衣服上的裂口一致。检方还声称，在阿扎里亚衣服上发现的九根动物毛发来自一只猫。《蓝皮书》澄清说，在墨尔本特恩布尔研究所进行的研究得出结论，其中两根毛发是人类的，一根无法确诊，其余六根是犬类的。另一份报告显示，张伯伦夫妇车内的一个血迹（检方辩称那是来自阿扎里亚颈部伤口的血雾）实际上是由一种含糖饮料和车辆制造过程中使用的隔音漆混合而成的。在审判期间，乔伊·库尔曾提交报告，解释了她如何对
the supposed blood stains and reached her conclusions. In particular, she detailed that she had used a certain type of antiserum to determine that the blood stains contained fetal hemoglobin. According to the Blue Book, the German manufacturer of the antiserum Kuhl used stated that the antiserum wasn't capable of determining such results, as it didn't respond exclusively to fetal hemoglobin and could also react to the presence of other proteins. On November 12, 1985, the Northern Territory Government rejected the Chamberlain Innocence Committee's application, stating, This campaign has, as its intended effect, the building up of antagonism toward the Northern Territory Government,
假定的血迹进行检查并得出结论。特别是，她详细说明了她曾使用某种类型的抗血清来确定血迹中含有胎儿血红蛋白。根据《蓝皮书》的记载，库尔使用的抗血清的德国制造商表示，该抗血清不具备确定此类结果的能力，因为它并非专门对外显胎儿血红蛋白产生反应，也可能对其他蛋白质的存在产生反应。1985年11月12日，北领地政府拒绝了张伯伦清白委员会的申请，并表示：这场运动的预期效果是，
which it seeks to portray as hard, cruel, and lacking in compassion. At stake is law and order, and faith in the due processes of a legal system recognised as the fairest in the world. Two weeks later, the government also rejected Lindy's application for early release. That same month, a book was published featuring the first in-depth exploration into the possibility that the Chamberlains were wrongfully convicted. Titled Evil Angels, the case of Lindy Chamberlain, it was written by John Bryson, a barrister who spent four years closely following the case, attending court sessions, and interviewing those involved. The book received critical acclaim, selling out its first print run in just 10 days, and cast a new light on the infamous case.
激起人们对北领地政府的敌意，试图将其描绘成冷酷、残忍且缺乏同情心的形象。事关法律与秩序，以及对被公认为世界上最公正的法律体系的正当程序的信任。两周后，政府还拒绝了林迪的提前释放申请。同年同月，一本新书出版，首次深入探讨了张伯伦夫妇被冤枉的可能性。该书名为《邪恶天使：林迪·张伯伦案》，由大律师约翰·布莱森撰写，他花四年时间密切关注此案、参加法庭庭审并采访了相关人员。该书获得了极高的评价，首印在短短10天内售罄，并为这起臭名昭著的案件带来了新的光亮。
In a review of Evil Angels for the Age newspaper, famed literary and cultural commentator Dignio Hearn wrote, Bryson demonstrates fairly and conclusively that Lindy Chamberlain is innocent, but his book also probes our society and reveals the warts, prejudice, and superstition lurking beneath our so-called 20th-century sophistication. Two months later, on Sunday, January 26, 1986, 31-year-old British traveller David Brett was exploring Uluru Katajuta National Park alone with the intention to climb Uluru. It was too hot to do so during the day, so he waited until 4pm, hoping the afternoon sun would subside and give way to a cool evening breeze. The facilities in the national park had changed significantly since Azaria Chamberlain's
在《时代报》对《邪恶天使》的一篇书评中，著名的文学和文化评论家迪尼奥·赫恩写道：“布莱森公正而确凿地证明了林迪·张伯伦是无辜的，但他的书也探究了我们的社会，揭示了潜伏在我们所谓的20世纪成熟文明之下的疮疤、偏见和迷信。”两个月后，即1986年1月26日星期日，31岁的英国游客大卫·布雷特独自探索乌鲁鲁-卡塔楚塔国家公园，打算攀登乌鲁鲁。白天天气太热，无法攀登，于是他等到下午4点，希望午后的烈日能够消退，迎来凉爽的晚风。国家公园内的设施自阿扎里亚·张伯伦
disappearance, and as David set out on the climb, a park ranger warned him that camping on Uluru was forbidden by the traditional owners of the land. David agreed to adhere to the local customs and continued on his journey. At 7.40pm, two local Indigenous people witnessed him climbing in a forbidden area and reported him to the park authorities. Rangers set out to remove the British tourist from the rock but were unable to locate him and assumed he must have left of his own accord. A week later, a tourist was hiking the base of Uluru when they came across David's body. He had fallen 200m to his death during the climb and his remains had been scavenged by animals. On February 2, park rangers conducted a search of the area in an attempt to recover all of his
失踪以来已经发生了重大变化，当大卫出发开始攀登时，一名公园护林员警告他，当地土地传统所有者禁止在乌鲁鲁露营。大卫同意遵守当地习俗，继续他的旅程。晚上7点40分，两名当地原住民目击他在禁区攀登，并向公园管理部门报告了此事。护林员出发将这名英国游客从岩石上带下来，但没能找到他，便以为他一定是自行离开了。一周后，一名游客在乌鲁鲁的山脚下徒步时，偶然发现了大卫的尸体。他在攀登过程中坠落200米身亡，遗体已被动物啃食。2月2日，公园护林员对该地区进行了搜查，试图找回他所有的
bones. The site was only 150m from where Wally Goodwin had found Azaria's clothing years earlier and featured many dingo lairs. Wild dogs had pillaged David's backpack and the rangers located several items of his clothing amongst the dry grass and shrubs. One ranger spotted something buried in the sand and bent over to inspect it. Although filthy, the heat and dry sands of the desert had preserved the item and left it in decent condition. It was a white knitted baby jacket with stiff sleeves and a button hanging from its neck by a thread. This was a significant breakthrough in the Chamberlain case. Lindy had always maintained that Azaria had been wearing a knitted matinee jacket on the
骨头。该地点距离沃利·古德温几年前发现阿扎里亚衣服的地方仅150米，周围有许多野狗巢穴。野狗掠夺了大卫的背包，护林员在干草和灌木丛中找到了他的几件衣物。一名护林员发现沙子里有什么东西被埋着，于是弯下腰去检查。虽然沾满了污垢，但沙漠的高温和干燥的沙子却保存了这个物品，让它保持在不错的状态。这是一件白色的针织婴儿夹克，有着硬挺的袖子，领口处有一根线挂着一个纽扣。这是张伯伦案中的一个重大突破。林迪一直坚称，阿扎里亚在
night she was taken by a dingo, but the prosecution dismissed her claim as a fanciful lie. The Chamberlain's lawyer Stuart Tipple received a tip-off about the find from a journalist. He submitted an urgent request to the Northern Territory Police Commissioner for access to the jacket for the purposes of identification. The Chamberlain Innocence Committee urged that forensic examination be carefully monitored with members from both the defense and prosecution present. On February 5, the matinee jacket was shown to Lindy, who broke down in tears and positively identified it as belonging to her daughter. During the murder trial, the prosecution's case had depended on there being no jacket. Its discovery not only disproved their assertions
被野狗叼走的当晚穿了一件针织日间夹克，但检方将她的说法斥为异想天开的谎言。张伯伦夫妇的律师斯图尔特·蒂普尔从一名记者那里得到了关于这一发现的线索。他向北领地警察局长发出紧急请求，要求为了鉴定的目的接触这件夹克。张伯伦清白委员会敦促对法医检验进行仔细监督，防辩双方均应有代表在场。2月5日，这件日间夹克被展示给林迪，她情绪崩溃，失声痛哭，并确切辨认出它属于她的女儿。在谋杀审判期间，检方的案情一直建立在没有这件夹克的基础上。它的发现不仅反驳了他们关于
that Lindy was a liar, but also provided an explanation for the lack of saliva on the jumpsuit, as the jacket would have been in direct contact with the dingo's mouth and absorbed the majority of it. The Chamberlain Innocence Committee called for immediate police intervention. Michael Chamberlain told reporters he and his wife intended to fight for an inquiry into the investigation, stating, I would rather face the grave than give up the fight to clear my name and to that of my wife. 12 days after Azaria's jacket was discovered, a royal commission into the Chamberlain case was announced. The Chief Minister of the Northern Territory directed Lindy be immediately released from prison on remission, allowing her unrestricted
林迪是个说谎者的断言，而且还解释了连体衣上缺乏唾液的原因，因为夹克会直接接触野狗的嘴并吸收大部分唾液。张伯伦清白委员会呼吁警方立即介入。迈克尔·张伯伦告诉记者，他和妻子打算争取对这起调查进行独立调查，并表示：“我宁愿面对坟墓，也不愿放弃洗清我和我妻子名誉的战斗。”在阿扎里亚的夹克被发现12天后，针对张伯伦案的皇家调查委员会宣布成立。北领地首席部长下令立即释放林迪以假释出狱，允许她不受限制地
access to legal advisers in preparation. Regardless of the outcome, the Northern Territory Attorney General confirmed that Lindy would not be returning to prison, subject to the usual conditions of good behavior. Michael was ecstatic, telling the Sydney Morning Herald, I have been emotional for the last four or five years. Now I am out of my mind. We will be fighting tooth and nail till we have cleared our names. A police escort followed Lindy from Barama Prison to New South Wales, where she was reunited with her family at the Avondale College Centre. Every tree along the driveway had been tied with a yellow ribbon, and a banner above the gates welcomed her home.
接触法律顾问以做准备。无论结果如何，北领地总检察长确认，在遵守通常的良好行为条款的前提下，林迪将不会再返回监狱。迈克尔欣喜若狂，他告诉《悉尼先驱晨报》：“在过去的四五年里，我一直情绪激动。现在我简直要乐疯了。我们将全力以赴，直到洗清我们的名誉。”一支警察护送队一路护送林迪离开巴里马监狱前往新南威尔士州，在那里她与家人在阿文代尔学院中心团聚。车道沿线的每一棵树都系上了黄丝带，大门上方的一条横幅欢迎她回家。
Carlia, who was now almost four years old, was returned to her mother's care. The media and public had a strong reaction to Lindy's release. Many remained convinced of her guilt and were outraged, while the number of her supporters also grew. Some people complained of the ongoing legal costs taxpayers would have to front, while others pointed out that the case served as a reminder of the fallibility of the Australian justice system, and the potential dangers had capital punishment not already been abolished. In a letter published in the Sydney Morning Herald, one reader stated, It is not a question of whether Lindy Chamberlain has paid her debt to society, but how society can possibly pay its debt to Lindy.
卡莉娅现在快四岁了，回到了母亲身边。媒体和公众对林迪的获释反应强烈。许多人依然确信她有罪并感到愤怒，而她的支持者数量也在增加。一些人抱怨纳税人将不得不承担源源不断的法律诉讼费用，而另一些人则指出，这起案件提醒人们注意澳大利亚司法系统的不可靠性，以及如果死刑尚未被废除可能带来的潜在危险。在《悉尼先驱晨报》发表的一封信中，一位读者写道：“这根本不是林迪·张伯伦是否已经偿还了她对社会的债务的问题，而是社会究竟该如何偿还它对林迪的债务。”
The Royal Commission commenced later that year and concluded 14 months later. Justice Trevor Moorling found that the prosecution's case relied heavily on expert testimony that Dingoes were highly unlikely to enter a tent and attack a child, but acknowledged they had not taken into account that the Uluru Dingoes were unlike typical wild Dingoes found elsewhere. He highlighted that local park rangers believed it was not only possible that one of the native Dingoes could take a baby from a tent, but had been concerned that an attack of such a nature might happen. Justice Moorling rejected assertions that Lindy Chamberlain was a bad mother or might have been suffering from postnatal depression, stating she was a loving and responsible parent
皇家调查委员会于同年晚些时候开始调查，并在14个月后得出结论。法官特雷弗·莫林发现，检方的案情很大程度上依赖于专家证词，即野狗极不可能进入帐篷袭击儿童，但他承认，他们没有考虑到乌鲁鲁的野狗与在其他地方发现的典型野生野狗不同。他强调，当地的公园护林员认为，本地野狗不仅有可能从帐篷里抱走婴儿，而且一直担心会发生这种性质的袭击。莫林法官驳斥了关于林迪·张伯伦是个坏母亲或可能患有产后抑郁症的断言，并指出她是一位慈爱且负责任的家长，
who had never manifested any symptoms to suggest she might be violent towards one of her children. He believed the grief Lindy displayed following Azaria's death was genuine, and that her renaissance in assisting with the search for her daughter could be explained by her early acceptance that Azaria was already deceased and her need to remain close to her two surviving children. In regards to the findings of infant blood under the dashboard in the Chamberlain's car, Justice Moorling accepted it was actually soundproofing pain. He also challenged the prosecution's timeline of events, pointing out that their case revolved around a 5-10 minute window in which Lindy had to return to the tent, ensuring Aiden didn't follow
从未表现出任何迹象表明她可能对自己的某个孩子使用暴力。他认为林迪在阿扎里亚死后表现出的悲痛是真诚的，她积极协助搜寻女儿的行为可以解释为她很早就接受了阿扎里亚已经死亡的事实，并且需要留在他俩仅存的两个孩子身边。关于在张伯伦夫妇车内仪表盘下方发现婴儿血迹的调查结果，莫林法官接受了这实际上是隔音漆的事实。他还对检方的事件时间线提出了质疑，指出他们的案件围绕着一个5到10分钟的时间窗口：林迪必须在此期间返回帐篷，确保艾丹没有跟着
her, change into her tracksuit pants, take Azaria to the car, find a murder weapon, cut Azaria's throat, allow sufficient time for Azaria to die, hide the body, clean up at least some of the blood in the car, change out of her tracksuit pants, obtain a can of baked beans for Aiden, return to the tent and deliberately leave blood spatter there, collect Aiden and return to the barbecue area. Justice Moorling declared that the prosecution had provided no evidence of the Chamberlain's guilt and absolved Lindy and Michael of any responsibility in their daughter's death. He concluded it was reasonable to believe that Aidengo had entered the tent and carried Azaria away with the intention of consuming her. In response, the Northern Territory Government
她，换上运动裤，把阿扎里亚带到车里，找到凶器，割开阿扎里亚的喉咙，留出足够的时间让阿扎里亚死去，藏匿尸体，清理车内至少一部分血迹，换下运动裤，给艾丹拿一罐烤豆，返回帐篷并故意在那里留下血迹，带上艾丹并返回烧烤区。莫林法官宣布，检方没有提供任何张伯伦夫妇有罪的证据，并宣告林迪和迈克尔在女儿的死中没有任何责任。他总结认为，有理由相信野狗曾进入帐篷并将阿扎里亚叼走，企图将其吃掉。作为回应，北领地政府
offered the Chamberlains a pardon. While this granted them clemency, it didn't officially clear them of their guilt. Lindy told the Sydney Morning Herald, I'm not interested in a pardon for something I haven't done. A pardon means absolutely nothing to me. Somebody up there must be confusing granting a pardon with squashing the conviction, and it's not even remotely the same. The following year, in September 1988, the Northern Territory Court of Criminal Appeals agreed with Justice Moorling's findings and quashed the Chamberlain's convictions. A film adaptation of John Bryson's book Evil Angels was released shortly after,
向张伯伦夫妇提供了特赦。虽然这给予了他们宽大处理，但并没有正式还他们清白。林迪告诉《悉尼先驱晨报》：“我对一项我没有做过的罪名的特赦不感兴趣。特赦对我来说毫无意义。楼上的某个人一定把特赦和撤销定罪搞混了，这两者简直有着天壤之别。”第二年，即1988年9月，北领地刑事上诉法院同意了莫林法官的调查结果，并撤销了对张伯伦夫妇的定罪。约翰·布莱森的书《邪恶天使》的电影改编版不久后上映，
starring Meryl Streep as Lindy and Sam Neal as Michael. The film divided Australian audiences. Lindy maintained it was a 95% accurate depiction of the events. Lindy and Michael sought restitution of $4 million from the Northern Territory Government for the pain, suffering, and loss of wages caused by their wrongful conviction. In 1992, the Attorney General announced that Lindy and Michael would receive compensation of $900,000 and $400,000 respectively. The amount was significantly lower than the Chamberlains had requested. When explaining why, a spokesperson for the Attorney General said the Northern Territory Government had no legal obligation to make the payment at all.
由梅丽尔·斯特里普饰演林迪，山姆·尼尔饰演迈克尔。这部电影在澳大利亚观众中引发了争议。林迪坚称，这是对事件95%真实准确的刻画。林迪和迈克尔向北领地政府索赔400万澳元，以赔偿冤假错案给他们造成的痛苦、折磨和工资损失。1992年，总检察长宣布，林迪和迈克尔将分别获得90万澳元和40万澳元的赔偿。这一金额远低于张伯伦夫妇的要求。在解释原因时，总检察长的一位发言人表示，北领地政府根本没有法律义务支付这笔赔偿。
The Sydney Morning Herald was highly critical of both the amount and the time it took for the Chamberlains to be financially compensated, with one editorial stating, whatever was eventually paid to the Chamberlains was always going to be a token arbitrary amount, since no money could truly compensate them for what they have suffered. The reprehensible attitude of the Northern Territory Government reflects what is still a significant sentiment against the Chamberlains in the community. It is just one of the tragedies of the Chamberlain case that the Northern Territory Government has shown itself incapable of leading instead of being swayed by the mob and afraid of taking unpopular decisions when justice and
《悉尼先驱晨报》对赔偿金额以及张伯伦夫妇获得经济赔偿所花费的时间提出了强烈批评，其中一篇社论指出：“无论最终支付给张伯伦夫妇多少钱，它始终都只能是一个象征性的任意金额，因为任何金钱都无法真正补偿他们所遭受的一切。”北领地政府应受谴责的态度反映出，社会上仍然存在针对张伯伦夫妇的强烈情绪。北领地政府表现得无力引领社会，反而受暴民左右，在正义与公平需要时不敢做出不受欢迎的决定，这正是张伯伦案诸多悲剧之一。
fairness required that. With the Chamberlains' convictions overturned, the second coronal inquest into Azaria's death in 1981 was deemed incomplete, and a third less involved inquiry was ordered to take place in December 1995. Coroner John Lowndes shared his findings, reiterating that neither Lindy nor Michael were involved with Azaria's disappearance in any way. However, he wasn't reasonably satisfied that her death could be proven to be the result of a dingo attack, and consequently recorded an open finding, noting the cause of Azaria's death as unknown. Coroner Lowndes acknowledged this finding would undoubtedly lead to further speculation that the nine-week-old's death was non-accidental, but clarified.
随着张伯伦夫妇的定罪被推翻，1981年针对阿扎里亚死因的第二次死因研讯被判定为不完整，并下令在1995年12月进行第三次涉及面较小的研讯。死因裁判官约翰·朗兹分享了他的调查结果，重申林迪和迈克尔绝对没有参与阿扎里亚的失踪。然而，他没有合理的确信能够证明她的死是野狗袭击的结果，因此记录了一项开放式裁决，指出阿扎里亚的死因不明。朗兹法官承认，这一裁决无疑会导致人们进一步猜测这个九周大婴儿的死并非意外，但他澄清说：
What is important, however, is that any such speculation, inevitable as it is, can never disturb the unassailable fact that as a matter of public record, the law of the land holds Mr. and Mrs. Chamberlain to be innocent. A decade later, in 2004, the Azaria-Chamberlain case made headlines again. 78-year-old Melbourne resident Frank Cole said he had been at all a rue on August 17, 1980, when he and his two companions encountered a dingo carrying a baby girl in its jaws. The baby's face and ear were badly mutilated and her head was covered in blood. Frank claimed he shot the dingo and the three men washed and cleaned the baby, but it then occurred to them that they might be tampering
然而，重要的是，任何此类猜测尽管不可避免，但也永远无法撼动一个不容置疑的事实：作为公开记录的一部分，国家法律认定张伯伦夫妇是无辜的。十年后的2004年，阿扎里亚·张伯伦案再次登上头条。78岁的墨尔本居民弗兰克·科尔表示，他曾在1980年8月17日身处乌鲁鲁，当时他和另外两名同伴遇到了一只野狗，它的嘴里叼着一个女婴。婴儿的脸和耳朵严重残缺，头部满是鲜血。弗兰克声称他向野狗开枪，三名男子清洗了婴儿，但随后他们意识到自己可能在破坏
with evidence, so they placed her body in a bag. Frank returned home ahead of his group, and the other two men said they would take the baby to the police. He wasn't sure what happened next, as they made a pact to never speak of it again. He believed one of the men may have buried the baby in the backyard of their suburban Melbourne home. Frank explained that he didn't come forward earlier out of fear he would be charged for firing a gun in a national park, but after suffering a serious accident, he felt he had to clear his conscience. Frank's two companions had since passed away, meaning there was no one to validate his claims. The home on the alleged burial site had since undergone major extensions, and its new owner
证据，于是将她的尸体放进了一个袋子里。弗兰克先于他的同伴们回到了家，另外两名男子说他们会把婴儿交给警方。他不太确定接下来发生了什么，因为他们曾立下誓言，永远不再提起此事。他相信其中一名男子可能将婴儿埋在了墨尔本郊区家中的后院里。弗兰克解释说，他没有早点站出来，是害怕自己因为在国家公园开枪而被起诉，但在经历了一场严重的事故后，他觉得必须求得内心安宁。弗兰克的两名同伴在此期间已经过世，这意味着没有人能证实他的说法。据称是埋尸地点的房屋此后经过了重大扩建，其新主人
told police they could only dig on his property if they produced tangible evidence of what they expected to find. An officer who was involved with the original investigation told ABC News that although the story was feasible, he held doubts about its authenticity. Lindy Chamberlain stated that if Frank's claims were true, she wouldn't hold any grudges against him for not coming forward sooner. Michael Chamberlain concurred, saying, I do forgive the man if he is telling the truth, and I would be happy for him to not be prosecuted because he's carried a very big cross. Both the Northern Territory and Victoria Police agreed to investigate Frank's claims, but with nothing to substantiate his story,
告诉警方，只有他们能拿出他们期望找到的实质性证据，才允许在自己房产上挖掘。一名参与最初调查的警官告诉澳大利亚广播公司（ABC），尽管这个故事听起来很合理，但他对它的真实性存疑。林迪·张伯伦表示，如果弗兰克的说法是真的，她不会因为他没有早点站出来而记恨他。迈克尔·张伯伦对此表示赞同，他说：“如果这个男人说的是真的，我原谅他，我也很高兴他没有被起诉，因为他背负了一个沉重的十字架。”北领地和维多利亚州警方均同意对弗兰克的说法展开调查，但由于没有任何证据来证实他的故事，
it was dismissed by the coroner, and ultimately went nowhere. The following year, in 2005, a 25-year-old woman came forward to the Alice Springs Police claiming to be Azaria Chamberlain. Erin Horsberg had been raised in foster care, but said she became suspicious about her real identity after she started having flashbacks to being carried in the jaws of a dingo at nine weeks of age. She had long thought she bore physical similarities to Lindy, a belief that was further exacerbated when she gave birth to a son whom she thought was the spitting image of Azaria. Erin told ABC Radio that she didn't have any other memories from infancy, but explained, I've got scars on my hands where dogs have bitten me and my foster mother couldn't
它被死因裁判官驳回，最终不了了之。第二年，即2005年，一名25岁的女子前往艾丽斯斯普林斯警察局，声称自己就是阿扎里亚·张伯伦。埃琳·霍斯伯格一直在寄养家庭长大，但她说，自从开始回想起自己在九周大时被野狗叼在嘴里的画面后，她开始对自己的真实身份产生怀疑。她一直认为自己在长相上与林迪相似，当她生下一个她认为和阿扎里亚长得一模一样的儿子时，这种信念进一步加深了。埃琳告诉澳大利亚广播公司电台，她没有其他婴儿时期的记忆，但她解释说：“我的手上有狗咬过的伤疤，而我的养母却说不出
tell me why. Her claims were ultimately dismissed. The Chamberlains continued campaigning to clear their names over the years. Although the Third Inquest had returned to their presumption of innocence, they sought full exoneration and wanted the official cause of Azaria's death changed from unknown to dingo attack. On August 17, 2010, exactly 30 years after Azaria's disappearance, Lindy published an open letter on her website, LindyChamberlain.com, calling on the Northern Territory Government to amend her daughter's death certificate. In response, the Northern Territory Attorney General advised that the power to make this change lay with the coroner's office. The following year, Northern Territory Deputy Coroner Elizabeth Morris announced that new
原因。”她的说法最终被驳回。多年来，张伯伦夫妇继续为洗清名誉而奔走。虽然第三次研讯恢复了他们无罪推定，但他们寻求彻底平反，并希望将阿扎里亚的官方死因从“不明”更改为“野狗袭击”。2010年8月17日，正值阿扎里亚失踪30周年之际，林迪在她的网站LindyChamberlain.com上发表了一封公开信，呼吁北领地政府修改她女儿的死亡证明。作为回应，北领地总检察长表示，做出这一更改的权力在于死因裁判官办公室。第二年，北领地副死因裁判官伊丽莎白·莫里斯宣布，有关野狗行为的新
revelations regarding dingo behaviour had emerged and she would be opening a Fourth Inquest into Azaria's death. That commenced in February 2012 with local newspaper NT News running a large photograph of Lindy on its front page beneath the headline She's Back. The proceedings centered around a series of dingo attacks that had occurred against children at Fraser Island, a popular tourist destination off the coast of Queensland. Between 2001 and 2011, a nine-year-old boy was killed by two dingoes on the island, a four-year-old girl was severely bitten, and a three-year-old girl suffered puncture wounds to her leg. A 2011 study of dingo scats was also submitted, which confirmed that, contrary to popular belief, dingoes preyed on larger mammals,
情况已经浮出水面，她将对阿扎里亚的死因展开第四次研讯。该研讯于2012年2月开始，当地报纸《北领地新闻》在头版头条刊登了林迪的大幅照片，标题为“她回来了”。庭审的焦点是一系列发生在昆士兰州海岸热门旅游目的地弗雷泽岛上的野狗袭击儿童事件。在2001年至2011年期间，一名九岁男孩在该岛被两只野狗杀死，一名四岁女孩被严重咬伤，一名三岁女孩的腿部被咬出伤口。一份2011年的野狗粪便研究报告也被提交，证实与普遍看法相反，野狗会捕食大型哺乳动物，
such as wallabies. In June 2012, Coroner Morris handed down her findings. Both Lindy and Michael were present to hear the outcome, along with their son Aidan, who was now in his late 30s. Coroner Morris announced she was satisfied that Azaria had died as a result of being attacked and taken by a dingo. She apologized to the chamberlains for all they had endured, stating, I am so sorry for your loss. Time does not remove the pain and sadness of the death of a child. Spectators applauded and the chamberlains wept before an amended death certificate for Azaria was made available for the family. Outside the courthouse, Lindy told reporters, we are relieved and delighted to come to the end of this saga. Michael thanked the coroner for her
例如小袋鼠。2012年6月，莫里斯死因裁判官公布了她的调查结果。林迪和迈克尔以及他们的儿子艾丹（现在已三十多岁）都出席了听证会。莫里斯死因裁判官宣布，她确信阿扎里亚是因为遭到野狗袭击并被叼走而死的。她为张伯伦夫妇所承受的一切道歉，并说道：“我为你们的失去感到非常抱歉。时间无法消除失去孩子的痛苦与悲伤。”旁观者们鼓掌喝彩，张伯伦夫妇泪流满面，随后该家族领到了修改后的阿扎里亚死亡证明。法院外，林迪告诉记者：“我们感到宽慰，并很高兴能走到这一传奇故事的终点。”迈克尔感谢死因裁判官的
finding, remarking, This has been a terrifying battle, bitter at times, but now some healing and a chance to put our daughter's spirit to rest. By the time Lindy and Michael were legally vindicated, the couple had separated and both since remarried. Lindy had released an autobiography titled Through My Eyes. Later retitled, The Dingoes Got My Baby, in which she explained the divorce was the result of issues that existed within their marriage prior to the loss of their daughter. The Azaria Chamberlain case captured the Australian media's attention like no other in the country's history, with the rampant publicity shaping the narrative of the story. In the early days of Azaria's disappearance,
裁决，并评论道：“这是一场可怕的战斗，有时很痛苦，但现在有了一些治愈，也有了一个机会让女儿的灵魂得以安息。”在林迪和迈克尔在法律上被证明清白时，这对夫妇已经分居，并且此后都各自再婚。林迪曾出版了一部自传，名为《透过我的双眼》。后来更名为《野狗叼走了我的孩子》，她在书中解释说，离婚是他们失去女儿之前婚姻中就存在的问题导致的。阿扎里亚·张伯伦案以前所未有的方式吸引了澳大利亚媒体的关注，猖獗的宣传塑造了故事的叙事。在阿扎里亚失踪的早期，
the press reported the incident as a dingo attack without question and supported the chamberlains wholeheartedly. But several weeks into the investigation, unsubstantiated rumors gained coverage and fuelled the public debate over the Chamberlain's guilt. Explaining why she chose to write a book about her ordeal, Lindy said, Someone has to have the courage to tell what happens to innocent Australians who are being torn in shreds to feed the megalomaniac media machine for our daily news. It's never been real the way the media reported it. It's never been true. I'd read the newspapers and the reports would bear no resemblance to what actually happened.
媒体毫无疑问地将这起事件报道为野狗袭击，并全心全意地支持张伯伦夫妇。但在调查几周后，未经证实的谣言获得了报道，并助长了公众对张伯伦夫妇是否有罪的争论。林迪在解释她为什么选择写一本关于自己遭遇的书时说道：“总得有人有勇气说出，那些无辜的澳大利亚人遭遇了什么，他们被撕成碎片，去喂养那个为了每日新闻而疯狂的媒体机器。媒体报道的方式从来都不是真实的。从来都不是真的。我读着报纸，上面的报道与实际发生的事情毫无相似之处。”
Lindy's book provided candid answers and personal insights into many misinterpreted, misleading and mistaken details about the case. She discredited speculation by revealing the innocent explanations for many of the damning pieces of evidence used against her. To account for why traces of blood were found on the nail scissors in the glove box of the Tarana, Lindy recalled she had used the scissors to cut a piece of Azaria's dried ambilical cord when she was five and a half weeks old. Afterwards, she wiped the scissors clean and didn't think she had left any blood on them. 30 years after the trial, ABC news reporter Tony Eastley wrote an article reflecting on his experience covering the case and the power it held over the Australian media,
琳迪的书对这起案件中许多被误解、误导和错误的细节提供了坦率的回答和个人见解。她通过揭示许多针对她的不利证据的无辜解释，驳斥了种种猜测。为了解释为什么塔拉纳手套箱里的美甲剪上会残留血迹，琳迪回忆说，阿扎里亚五周半大时，她曾用这把剪刀剪过她干枯的脐带。事后，她把剪刀擦干净了，并不觉得上面还留有血迹。审判结束30年后，澳大利亚广播公司新闻记者托尼·伊斯利写了一篇文章，反思了他报道该案的经历及其对澳大利亚媒体的巨大影响，
stating, It was a circus. The trial was a tabloid editor's dream. There was Australia's mysterious outback, wild dingos, a small camping ground in the shadows of the giant monolith so central to Aboriginal dreaming, and a pastor and his young wife, both members of a relatively unknown and certainly misunderstood religion. Lindy was particularly vilified, with the focus shifting from her daughter to her demeanor, her choice of outfits, and her attractiveness. In November 2014, Lindy participated in a New York Times documentary on the case, telling the filmmakers, If I smiled, I was belittling my daughter's death. If I cried, I was acting. The point is, until you go through something, you have no idea how you yourself will react. I had no idea how I'd
并指出：“这是一场马戏团。这场审判是小报编辑的梦想。这里有澳大利亚神秘的内陆、野狗、一个巨大独石山阴影下的小露营地（这座独石山对原住民的梦幻时光至关重要）、一个牧师和他的年轻妻子，他们都是一个相对鲜为人知且肯定被误解的宗教的成员。”琳迪受到的恶评尤其严重，焦点从她的女儿转移到了她的举止、她的衣着选择以及她的吸引力上。2014年11月，琳迪参与了一部关于该案的《纽约时报》纪录片，她对电影制片人说：“如果我笑了，我就是在贬低我女儿的死。如果我哭了我就是在演戏。重点是，在你经历某些事情之前，你根本不知道自己会作何反应。我完全不知道自己会
react until it happened to me. The prosecution's dubious arguments at trial also had a profound impact on perceptions of Lindy. Dura Havon Kane empathised with the mother when she first saw her in court, as her own son had been bitten by a dingo when he was a baby. But she was soon convinced by the prosecution's evidence, and her opinion swayed towards Lindy's guilt. After the trial, when Lindy was behind bars, Havon became convinced she had made a huge mistake and was deeply troubled. When Lindy was released, the two women met in person and formed an ongoing friendship. Havon told Weekly News Magazine Newsweek that she is still plagued with guilt and believes that all Australians who condemned Lindy should feel the same way. Quote,
作何反应，直到它发生在我身上。”控方在审判中可疑的论点也对人们对琳迪的看法产生了深远的影响。杜拉·哈沃恩·凯恩在法庭上第一次看到琳迪时对这位母亲感同身受，因为她自己的儿子在婴儿时期就被野狗咬过。但她很快就被控方的证据说服了，她的观点转变为琳迪有罪。审判结束后，当琳迪身陷囹圄时，哈沃恩开始确信自己犯了一个巨大的错误，并陷入了深深的困扰。琳迪获释后，两位女性亲自见面并结成了长期的友谊。哈沃恩告诉《新闻周刊》，她至今仍被内疚感折磨，并认为所有谴责琳迪的澳大利亚人都应该有同感。她说，
Because if the dingo is guilty, then so is Australia. An article in the Age newspaper explored the gendered nature of the criticism that surrounded Lindy, stating, Many of those who believed Lindy Chamberlain guilty maintained that the baby had been killed in some kind of obscure sacrificial ritual, so it's deeply ironic that the trial itself turned out to be a sacrificial ritual on a national scale. Those who claimed that the name Azaria meant sacrifice in the wilderness spoke more truly than they knew. They simply mistook the identity of the victim. To this day, Lindy Chamberlain's commonly misquoted cry that a dingo ate my baby is infamous
“因为如果野狗有罪，那么澳大利亚也有罪。”《时代报》的一篇探讨围绕琳迪的批评具有性别色彩的文章指出：“许多认为琳迪·张伯伦有罪的人坚信，这个婴儿是在某种晦涩的祭祀仪式中被杀害的，因此这场审判本身最终演变成一场全国规模的祭祀仪式，具有极大的讽刺意味。那些声称‘阿扎里亚’这个名字在荒野中意味着牺牲的人，比他们想象的更切中要害。他们只是认错了受害者。”直到今天，琳迪·张伯伦那句经常被误引的呐喊“野狗吃了我的孩子”，在全世界依然声名狼藉，
around the world. In the United States, the phrase has become something of a pop culture phenomenon and has been employed as a punchline in many famous television shows, including The Simpsons, Seinfeld, Buffy the Vampire Slayer and Frasier. Experts have speculated that foreigners may not have understood the seriousness of the event associated with the phrase and were amused by the word dingo due to their unfamiliarity with Australian Aboriginal languages. Over the years, there have been numerous adaptations of the case for stage and screen, including an opera, a miniseries, and a play inspired by the 20,000 letters Lindy received over the decades.
在美国，这句话已经成了一种流行文化现象，并被用作许多著名电视节目的笑料，包括《辛普森一家》、《宋飞正传》、《捉鬼者巴菲》和《欢乐一家亲》。专家推测，外国人可能并不理解与这句话相关的事件的严重性，而且由于不熟悉澳大利亚原住民语言，他们觉得“野狗”这个词很有趣。多年来，该案曾多次被改编为舞台剧和银幕作品，包括歌剧、迷你剧以及一部灵感来自琳迪几十年来收到的2万封信件的戏剧。
The National Museum of Australia in Canberra hosts more than 350 artifacts relating to the case, including Azaria's infamous black dress souvenirs sold during the trial and courtroom sketches. Lindy helped curate the collection, which led to further public criticism as some accused her of exploiting her experiences. In 2014, the museum purchased the family's yellow Tirana hatchback, with the museum director explaining the collection would ensure the Chamberlain story was never forgotten. In a subsequent interview with ABC News, Michael Chamberlain stated, What I want them to note in a nutshell is that this car has survived, not only as a symbol of a
位于堪培拉的澳大利亚国立博物馆收藏了350多件与此案相关的物品，包括阿扎里亚那件声名狼藉的黑色连衣裙、审判期间出售的纪念品以及法庭素描。琳迪协助策划了这批藏品，这引发了更多的公众批评，一些人指责她利用自己的经历。2014年，博物馆购买了这家人黄色的蒂拉娜掀背车，博物馆馆长解释说，这批藏品将确保张伯伦的故事永远不会被遗忘。在随后接受澳大利亚广播公司新闻采访时，迈克尔·张伯伦表示：“简而言之，我想让他们注意的是，这辆车不仅作为……的象征存活了下来，
gigantic forensic stuff up, but ultimately as a symbol of a triumph of Australian justice. On January 9, 2017, Michael Chamberlain passed away at the age of 72 after a year-long battle with acute leukemia. His memorial service was held at Avondale College, where more than 650 mourners gathered to pay their respects. Pastor Justin Lawman, president of the Seventh Day Adventist Church in northern New South Wales, said, Michael was a real advocate for the rights of the local people. He will be deeply missed. Allaroo has undergone significant changes since Azaria's disappearance. In the early 1970s, it was decided that all accommodation within the National Park
这是一次巨大的法医失误，但最终也是澳大利亚正义胜利的象征。”2017年1月9日，迈克尔·张伯伦在与急性白血病斗争了一年后去世，享年72岁。他的追悼会在阿文代尔学院举行，650多名哀悼者聚集在那里向他致敬。新南威尔士州北部基督复临安息日会会长贾斯汀·劳曼牧师说：“迈克尔是当地人民权利的真正倡导者。人们将深切怀念他。”自从阿扎里亚失踪以来，乌卢鲁经历了巨大的变化。在20世纪70年代初，人们决定逐步取消国家公园内的所有住宿设施，以尽量减少对环境的不利影响，露营活动也逐渐被淘汰。1983年，张伯伦夫妇停留的艾尔斯岩露营地被永久关闭。尽管攀登乌卢鲁违背了其传统主人阿南古人的文化和法律，但多年来攀登活动仍然被允许。2019年10月，攀登活动被正式废除，成千上万的人涌向该地区，在古老遗址关闭前最后一次攀登。今天，琳迪和她的丈夫里克住在亨特谷。她写过关于悲伤和宽恕的书籍，并就压力、监狱、
be removed over time in order to minimise adverse environmental effects and camping was gradually phased out. In 1983, Ares Rock Campground, where the Chamberlain stayed, was permanently closed. Climbing Allaroo was permitted for many years, despite being against the culture and law of its traditional owners, the Ananoo people. In October 2019, the climb was officially abolished, with thousands of people flocking to the area to scale the ancient site one final time before it closed. Today, Lindy lives in the Hunter Valley with her husband, Rick. She has written books on grief and forgiveness and gives seminars and lectures on a variety of topics such as stress, prison,
宗教以及媒体和法律的责任等各种主题举办研讨会和讲座。琳迪在她的网站上反思这起案件时写道：“这是一个小女孩的故事，她活着，呼吸着，爱着，也被爱着。她是我的一部分，她在我的体内生长，当她死去时，我的一部分也死去了，没有什么能改变这个事实。这是她的故事，也是我的故事。这样一个丑闻怎么会发生在澳大利亚这样一个以‘公平竞争’观念为傲的国家呢？引发这场大火的火花似乎没有单一的原因，但一旦火花燃起，就有许多人乐见狂热和不宽容的火焰被扇动。这里面肯定有一个有用的教训。”
religion, and the responsibilities of the media and the law. Reflecting on the case on her website, Lindy writes, This is the story of a little girl who lived and breathed and loved and was loved. She was part of me, she grew within my body, and when she died, part of me died, and nothing will ever alter that fact. This is her story and mine. How could such a scandal occur in Australia, a country that prides itself on its concept of the fair go? There appears to be no single reason that created the spark that started the Inferno, but once it was started, there were many who were happy to see the flames of bigotry and intolerance fanned. Surely there must be a useful lesson in there somewhere.
在琳迪的书《野狗抓走了我的孩子》中，她回顾了她期待已久的女儿的诞生，以及阿扎里亚在他们共度的九周里产生的强大影响。她写道：“有时候，一连几个小时，我晚上会坐起来，把阿扎里亚抱在怀里亲热。我多么庆幸自己当时这么做了。我有那段特殊的时光可以回味。她知道自己是被需要的，她爱她的家人，她对所有人的回应都非常高兴，尽管她年纪还小，但很明显她知道自己被爱着。”这里还没有关于这一集的评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
In Lindy's book, The Dingos Got My Baby, she reflects on the birth of her long-awaited daughter and the powerful impact Azaria made in the nine weeks they shared together. She writes, Sometimes, for hours at a time, I would sit up at night just holding Azaria in my arms and cuddling her. How glad I am that I did. I have got that special time to look back on. She knew she was wanted, she loved her family, she responded to them all very happily, and despite her tender age, it was obvious that she knew she was loved. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请跳过